[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
foreign
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello guys and welcome to the opening
event for the dragon ball fighterz world
championship tyrant range here to hold
you down hold it down for you guys man
that is that video is so sick i'm so
hyped
yeah man it's gonna be a great way to
kick it off bruh you of course the
supreme dj hours for you my man 4 am
you've been working like mad and you're
here once again holding it down with me
to represent the united states west
coast tonight oh my goodness yeah it's
gonna be super good man like it's really
exciting uh we've got some great players
out there uh ready to throw down for you
guys but before we get into the action i
just want to break down the format with
you guys uh a little here so we're going
to talk about you know what is the
dragon ball fighters world championship
you know what's different this year
what's changed um for the esports side
of things so yeah we're going to get
over with uh we're going to get going
with that very very soon um
so yeah it's gonna be cool but yeah it's
it's good to see you again man it's good
to see you back on the back of the
dragon fighter side of stuff you know
you'd love to see it
of course man this game you know it did
a lot for my life it changed my life and
i love this game through and through so
i'm glad to be back of course talking
about it and always ripping the west
coast as well that's definitely been my
home and native land since i was a pub
so glad to see them representing here as
well we got some familiar faces and
whatnot but as you mentioned there's
going to be a regional competition all
in all types of places right yeah
absolutely yeah from all over so uh just
a quick rundown guys of what uh the
national championship
championship see i got myself mixed up
so that's the point of today we're gonna
explain be explaining to you guys what's
different about the world championship
this year white snow different to the
national championship and things like
that so um so let's get over and just
bring it up for you guys real quick
because i have a bunch of slides here
that we can talk about and uh discuss so
of course the dragonfly's world
championship you know it's going to be
very very different this year um it's
going to be a different format point
system in place we're going to get to
that in a moment
so
this is the order in which it's going to
go down guys of course the world
championship tenkaichi online challenge
is what we're starting that's what we're
kicking off today so we are going to be
looking at um you know
why what are these online technology
challenges what is that all about you
know we're going to be leading up to the
regional finals coming up in december um
and then of course the world
championship finals which will be early
2022.
so
this is going to be our first stop
around the tenkaichi online challenge
exactly it's the first stop you know
we're gonna be kicking off with um of
course north america west um we've got
the
so so the online is uh broken into two
parts
we've got the community tournaments
which is uh of course the events that
the tos are running from all over over
you know that's the ones that they've
signed up for to have the points
distributed then of course we have the
official
the um the official events here the
master challenges ran by abandoned
entertainment
that's one of the ones that's happening
today um you know we've got more points
online for that one as you can see right
here in the points breakdown ridge
oh indeed so yeah we got first for the
tenkaichi online master challenge and
that is what's going down today you're
getting the big 200 points all the way
down 150 100 you can see the way it
breaks down 17th even getting a single
point and then of course the tenkaichi
online challenges the more community ran
event once are gonna be dependent on how
many entrants for those tournaments that
they get right so you can see 64 plus
players you're gonna have 100 48 plus
players 70 for first place etc down the
line so it's all about how many people
sign up so if you're going to be a part
of these community run tournaments
encourage your local scene to get as
many players in as possible that way you
get as many points as possible exactly
you want to make your events you know as
big and as beautiful as possible so we
can get all those um those points to
attribute to you guys and you can uh
earn a spot you know in the uh
in the in the world championship you
know we want you guys to represent your
regions and uh holding it down so yeah
it should be really really cool guys
um yeah you know it's cool to see you
know ben and namco take some of the
things that they implemented that were
very well received in the tekken world
tour you know to hear the dragon ball
fighters world tour as well this is like
the dojo events from that so it's pretty
much a mirror and i mean it was an
incredible thing to start big ups to the
hudo for his part in that as well and
you know i'm glad to see it here for
dragon ball as well
exactly yeah yeah it's really really
cool man um that's of course you know
that
what we went for there the the systems
it doesn't matter you know the to's if
you yeah you can choose you can even
have that on pc or ps4 you know the um
the official events will be around on pc
um but the
uh yeah but the tos can decide you know
which platforms they want to run their
events on um
so it's up to you guys you know if you
don't leave the ps4 guys out so
yeah you know every any anyone's ready
to play
hell yeah man that is a great look
indeed yeah leaving me up to the
community and then the official events
on pc as well i mean that i think is
very much uh from the feedback of the
community so it's great to see the
cooperation absolutely absolutely
um of course guys you can see right
there on the screen right now this is
the um different regions that we're
going to be running for the uh for the
online events
and then leading up to the regional
finals which is going to be happening in
december which is going to be really
really crazy uh we're on the fourth and
fifth of december we're going to have
the europe regional finals uh 11th and
12th will be the us so consisting of the
western east coast and then of course
the 18th and 19th december will be the
japan regional finals
and that's all offline guys it's all
going to be held offline
yeah exactly
super sick yeah and this is why the
points are important because look the
the four spot qualifiers are going to be
the ones that have earned the points and
earned us the right to be there as well
as uh invited players from each region
that are of course the strongest in
there
yes yes yes and you can see the full
mountain screen right there range so if
you want to break that down for people
at home that'd be excellent brother
oh yes indeed so as tyron mentioned
right that's how we're going to get our
players to start out with the 12 but
then we're going to get the round robin
format which i'm always a big fan of
right that's gonna be everybody playing
against everybody or it's gonna be
groups however they decide to break it
down it's gonna be a lot of matches to
determine how he gets that final bracket
and from there of course we will crown a
regional champion i mean yeah always
more games and i just like the fact that
it has that aspect of more people
getting to play against each other and
just in general a warm-up before that
final bracket if you will
exactly
so this is how it's going to break down
guys the four top players from the
regional finals the ones that um really
have you know shown themselves proven
themselves to be the strongest we'll
move on to the world championship finals
so um
yeah it's going to be really exciting to
see who makes it through there
and this is how it's all going to work
out so
of course
the top four places from the europe uh
will be there the um the
top two from each you know each
usa coast west and east will be making
it through to the finals in early 2022.
the top four from japan will go through
and of course these four fast track
events that's going to be crazy to see
qualifies out of these ones mexico
australia brazil of course middle east
and africa
will have tournaments online to
um make them those spots as well so yeah
it's gonna be crazy it's gonna be really
interesting man to see which top 16 we
get for that dragon ball fight as well
championship final
that's a really awesome way to round it
out into a 16-man bracket who with the
the mexico australia brazil and the mea
the uh yeah middle east for the first
place as well so it's gonna be sick man
of course and of course guys if you want
to participate you can uh register right
now the dragon ball fights esports
portland's open so be sure to register
your interest as a player and not only
that as a tournament organizer if you
want your tournaments to be on the tour
if you want to be on the world
championship you need to be signed up
through the dragon fights esports portal
you can find that on the bamboo namco
esports twitter page and you can uh yeah
you can get your tournaments up there
and you can have your community
represented officially in the world
championship this year which is it's
really cool man
yeah i already saw spooky has one for
you know lbc because they always been
running the online events throughout the
pandemic and whatnot and even before
always running the dragon ball offline
so it's great to see you know those
community events be a part of the world
tour and go into a contributing factor
to see who actually makes it to that
finals exactly yeah really really cool
stuff all right guys so um with the
breakdown complete i think we're almost
ready to get into our first match of the
day and i am so ready for some games man
i am so ready for the action
indeed indeed i was taking a look at the
top eight earlier as well some familiar
faces some players looking to rise to
the occasion as well and get some early
points as you can see the way it breaks
down right now we got scientific in the
building and zayn gonna be going up
against each other in one half of winter
semifinals and then gonna get yoma and
alakovic playing against each other in
the other semifinals and then we got tct
and jake ryan down to losers ezq and
apology man as well it's looking good
yeah it's gonna be crazy man man like
the interesting one for me here's man
like jake ryan going up there yeah this
guy's not only only talks about the game
he's playing it as well when he's doing
work so
you can't argue with that if he's up
there in the top eight of this at this
tournament he's got himself points
we might see him in the finals
my man jake ryan yeah he's like i'm
gonna get there one way or another
brother either i'm talking about it or
i'm playing about it you know what i'm
saying that's what i like to see the
determination yeah you do yeah i i do
love to see that you know it kind of
inspires me to get out there and uh do
some work as well you know i have to try
and represent so yeah it should be cool
but um yeah i think we are just about
ready to kick things off here of course
scientific versus zayn will be the first
game up on the board today guys
um
it should be interesting man i'm looking
forward to seeing what teams the the the
west coast crew are rocking at the
moment bro i'm looking forward to it
say it man because i'll tell you what
historically west coast not just the
dragon ball fighters but throughout the
fighting game
landscape they've always picked some
funky teams yeah
there's always been some like weird
synergetic they always try to go against
the grain a little bit create their own
meta so it's definitely i think kind of
followed that trend in dragon ball
fighters so i am interested as well
yeah yeah it should be great man already
okay
all right i think the gentleman already
yeah man for me it's crazy because like
i i literally traveled home from uh from
a local
because we ran a tournament earlier
today uh we did offline in london uh and
of course you know i get to hold this
down here of you as well i get that a
lot of the privilege of doing this as
well which is actually really i'm so
excited to kick off the world
championship so there's no way i was
missing this
dj hours but i'm ready i'm here for it
i'm ready
you know what i'm talking about brother
now you're on the side you know what i'm
saying yeah up at 4am over here yeah
normal hours for you in the years right
right right the tables have turned in a
good way this time you know at least for
me
boss all right okay i see you i'll see
you at scene
yeah but it's scientific you know one of
the players in our first winter semis
he's been playing this game since launch
like grinding hell yeah online offline
like he has been about it so i'm
definitely looking for him to come out
of this perhaps going into winners
finals but zayn i'm unfamiliar with him
but i mean if he's here he's gonna have
skills so maybe catch scientific off
guard a little bit or maybe they're more
familiar with each other than i think
yeah yeah i'm looking forward to seeing
how this one goes down for sure but the
gentlemen are getting ready i'm seeing
them getting ready to throw hands so
let's get into it guys
first game right here let's go what i am
talking about bro some dragon ball
fighters my man scientific with the use
ethernet and you know he's been about
the cheap stuff so i played this man in
multiple fighting games online look at
this coming out with the super saiyan 4
to piccolo the tn he's new meta and he
knows what he wants right for sure
guys i will be and in the game sound at
the moment after this uh set so just
bear with me we're gonna have to have uh
asmr gaming over here for the first set
so
just deal with it for now but yeah let's
get into it okay right now zamasu spark
up early okay i see you
yeah there's a little bit of a scary
sparkles all right
that out nah so spark pretty much wasted
at this point gonna set up shop as well
yeah there we go double jump okay oh my
goodness look at this and the beerus
assist in there as well okay oh i
actually clicked the piccolo but no
follow-up ring
yeah i could actually convert from that
uh clip wow i'm just gonna put out the
helmet on the neutral like this and take
him out of the sky one way or another
okay oh wow great block right there on
the ex shoulder but there we go here we
go full combo now
big green this character hits so hard
he knows he has so many ways to set up
dude
all right there we go oh we tried it
again but it was the 2m that's gonna be
so much damage right there oh no he
dropped the green jump that's a shame
he can't be doing that
lots of damage that's on the table at
that point for scientific and yeah he's
already had some opportunities that cost
him so you know we don't want to give
you a point anymore
he just turned around on him like that
that was a trick shot if i ever saw one
beerus okay oh wait he got he actually
had them both in there but it doesn't
matter
gogeta gets out but there's still a good
amount of damage here on piccolo um got
a little bit of blue there on gogeta
coming in as well so it's a good
position for zayn right
yeah definitely already vanquished one
character and he's got the beers on deck
too is i mean we both assist back and
i'm definitely gonna be a problem point
character you see good difficult
oh you thought it was your turn
well i've got news brother it's not
okay that was too good for scientific
right there keeping his characters alive
trying to maintain some neutral but
still can get a big oh oh anything big
started however you just find it here
now
yeah very nice
bro this character let me tell you okay
here we go the wake up buttons from zane
this man was pressing sweat
yeah he was loving him
okay okay tricky stuff nice blocking the
wall yeah good stuff and look at that
the flight this character now he is he
is moving
you mean to actually put the nos on his
jet pack as well
oh the x slash right there
oh the uptake gets himself out of that
block stun situation oh your beer is
coming in clutch
[Music]
jesus
tag team of the year right there that
was definitely it was a combination
maneuver for real that was that was uh
putting the bucks to shame right there
with that one theorist coming in
holding it down
yeah and zayn's doing a great job over
here just like kind of maintaining
neutral control he's got great
characters to do it with zamasu and
beerus doesn't get clipped on the across
uh but doesn't follow up instead dragon
rushes opens him up again one way or
another
yeah i think this
i don't know maybe yeah i wasn't i
wasn't convinced
needed a bit more juice on that one all
tech on the dr zane
gets out and zamasu oh the command grab
that was party time
that was good right there that was real
real good okay i see you scientific
the command where party bro
okay all goes behind nice definitely
have to
like the way you cover the crossover
with the 21 assists oh no all right you
know catching the startup just a wild
scramble the scientific is going to come
out on top of yeah oh he needed okay
this this will not kill um
not sure if there was any route you
could have done there that would have
got the kill actually without any bars
okay oh that's gonna do it the challenge
right there from zayn who takes the
first game up on the board and of course
guys until we get to winners uh losers
grand finals it's still two out of three
oh
oh
yeah i'm talking about i like that backs
against the wall real quick you know
you better make your adjustments now
yeah you better be ready fellas
okay
like i said guys before we will get i
will be putting audio on after this set
so uh yeah
just bear with it for now
okay that's just drawing that will be
remedied oh yeah oh my goodness
wow defense though man like scientific i
love this zamasu bro he's so sick of his
version yeah he's ridiculous man like
people were saying how they wanted him
to be
they gave him that and then some
yeah nice challenge as well dragon rush
stuffed out during the startup scene
once again in control
was feeling the heat right there my
man's [ __ ] up
oh again i just don't think he actually
wanted the purple lightning summon
probably getting crossed up or just some
type of execution error either way
scientific hazard on the core now drags
him out with a spark instead from zane
yeah he forced the blue combo there just
to uh limit the amount of damage you've
got in that situation but right now
scientifically in control
oh and then 21 is this is so potent man
just going to super dash behind me right
there get the knock down for dragon rush
yeah we didn't even get c21 at all in
the first match man like she's she's
such a strong character one of the best
in the game without doubt and you know
zayn had her in the back the whole time
that's kind of scary
yeah exactly right i mean she is a super
great on point oh that was nice to
cancel to the level three yeah he was
committed didn't have the reflection but
we're right back at your purple city
oh man look at tien manchin got punched
up as well
oh you're right yeah yeah
40 on the blue life here zayn could
perhaps get it oh we finally see the 21
but it gets bought by the tien assist
yeah it's too much blue like there to
leave yeah i respect it bring him in
take it take away that life
and scientific bring out that commander
these super super clutch moments i don't
know yeah like i have not seen either of
those coming at all like it was nasty so
sneaking them in there yeah like this is
the season of the command grab bro they
all got pretty much improved to be
honest
but yeah i mean that is one of the
things that bears has been good at for a
while right there's so much range on
that crouch medium catches the toes
that's not going to kill but you know
that's some good damage right there
downtech into the the raw tag
okay here we go ready for the the
downside too you saw the music oh my
goodness but scientific not respecting
the range from beerus ah absolutely not
by the mother
they reflect there the challenge as well
oh you didn't get a conversion that's a
heartbreaker right there but still
good tech though
i'm liking that
look at this
[Music]
[Music]
got him out of that tech situation okay
there we go
hold on
wait a second oh we're going to convert
that would have been the kill on beerus
unfortunate
it's very very back and forth neutral
man no one really taking full advantage
okay scientific now oh there it is
but again
nowhere near enough damage gonna switch
out to android 21.
i like that though yeah i'm gonna get at
least an ability still here a lot of
blue life on scientific you know we
didn't want to be linear about it but
actually does risk attack waited until
zane took to the sky was going to be
more tough to contest from there but a
clean whiff punish that should be the
kill on super saiyan 4 and now tien
coming back in and losing that blue life
anyway
this is it this could be zayn's ticket
into the winner's finals guys he just
needs to defeat one more character just
need to take down tien
bro
how on earth
did he convert that
that was range on the tail son holy
smokes
that was crazy and with that guy zane
takes it and he's going to advance to
the winner's final bro that was kind of
crazy like
that was like the hit's
yeah yeah for sure right the the
headstone just like it felt like
reminiscent of like like old akuma
assist or something where it was just
always a soft knockdown you know or just
like he's not gonna stop till he
actually reaches the ground and he got
him just before that moment yeah that
was i mean great stuff from zane staying
on the ball and making sure that he
tried for that conversion because i
thought it was too late but clearly it
was not yeah yeah that was that was
really really cool stuff man you love to
see it good awareness on that as well
and
android 21 is just such a good character
this season like i think that like
she they're definitely just
like like no characters got nerfed right
yeah but she like like a buffed they
were like she's one of the characters
that not only got buffed like actually
got like nice changes but the system
mechanics of the game like really help
right now she can switch out like you
saw she can get like the steals a lot
easier uh things like that her level
three okay is still probably the best in
the game let's be honest so
yeah she's a she's she's a beast man
yeah exactly i mean i i made that mean
for a week a reason you know i'm saying
i have my my android waifu saying which
side i want the oaky to hit on that's
what she does bro the level three is so
good i mean yeah as we mentioned that we
didn't even much see her much on point
in that set and her assist is mad good
too right that yes this is so fast beam
properties pops up like it is it is
potent it's crazy good super good guys
let's be real she's
she's pretty damn strong let's be honest
um but yeah uh it's interesting to see
what teams we're going to be seeing and
man zayn with that kind of unorthodox
squad i mean i i say that
we've seen a bit more zamasu now we've
kind of seen like how this character can
really just chop it up and
how strong he is um
and yeah i feel like he fits into a lot
more different team compositions now um
yeah so you know it's it's nice to see a
lot more character variety these days um
you know some characters it's and
another thing that's interesting is
seeing how some characters that were so
strong before kind of left to the
wayside now like yamcha is kind of a
rarity these days you know what i'm
saying
he is gone
he's a man at the bench
he's in the seventh inning stretch
that's what he's doing right now you
know what i'm saying
cheering from the bleachers but i also
uh really liked zayn's uh beerus too i i
thought the like airdp usage we saw a
couple of clutch situations where he
used that and like scrambles and that's
a really good option beerus has just to
kind of nullify whatever you were gonna
go with in that situation so definitely
good stuff i like the team like i said a
lot of neutral control and i think
that's very potent powerful in dragon
ball fighters so good stuff to say man
at least top three so that's a lot of
points definitely definitely definitely
you know like those masters points
really nice gonna be a good start to the
season for you if you do well in this
tournament here today
yes
right here guys we do have the fellas
ready to go um so all right and again we
talk about team variety man we got those
unlocked look we got like we got videl
jiren
come on man i like that the variety is
out here this season
yeah most definitely and i mean super
baby 2 is already like you know a little
bit more of a popular character but i
always like watching him
yeah yeah he's he's
don't test this man alchemist bro i'm
telling you i've seen him play a little
bit he's a young blood he's got the
reaction okay
whoa
all the vanishes geez all right
yeah i think if i'm not mistaken dragon
ball fighters is like his first fighting
game that he's taking me seriously so
he's definitely one of those one of the
ones that has been born from this game
yeah you'd love to see it man like
there's a lot of players like that and
you look at some of the talent you've
got like
pretty much all of the french crew um
that is them so you know what i'm saying
and that's a lot of talent right there
okay
man not ready there but that will be the
alien gone
yeah yoma is now ready for the super
dash kind of meta afterwards the mutual
gain that albuquerque was gonna play
just sort of fell with the butt and he
wasn't ready
nice conversion yeah i was ready right
there
like a [ __ ]
and he's going to get the corner here as
well should be able to get a good
situation fidel might be in trouble
oh what you dodging
you gotta trust your other senses bro
see you soon
ends up getting kovich in trouble now
knock down let's go
fidel
here we go put the boots in boom
and she's she's super overlooked man
like i feel oh
like oh man tyrone was about to launch
into a little monologue about
and then there's just like interrupted
cut off now
way to blow me up man i was just waiting
for something like the
mixture but no
i got denied man come on
that was definitely though that was like
a commentator 50 50. we guess sometimes
where it's like okay he might do
something that makes the character look
really cool so let me build it up and
then yeah right
you're like all right
oh my god oh wait a minute no
that's a shame the medium dunk actually
dropped brolly out the combo because you
know that wall bounce will do that in a
happy birthday situation man that's a
shame
like some characters have have it easy
there their combos you know keep them
doesn't use up the wall bounce whatever
but right now alikovic sparks up to
guarantee it piccolo cooking should be
able to get the kill of course he is
that's going to be the first game on the
board
his knees are so violent
yeah man like that jump knee oh
yeah
from the beginning bruh he's always very
impactful
man like piccolo so that was uh
yeah this is this i'm pretty sure this
is uh one of the stronger shells in the
game man like if you like
the piccolo and zebralish bro come on
yeah
the algorithm is playing i think a very
very strong team in this patch honestly
including the blue boot like all these
characters are super powerful i totally
agree i feel like blue goku is
definitely up there
you know in a similar position as
a lot of characters in the game kind of
overlooked very very strong very capable
okay here we go
[Music]
oh the dragon she did not take that
like the bullies is available as well
see i think you guys use it set up shop
here gonna spark up your mind as well
and take the mix
okay
back's off actually
bro look at that
reality stone bro where you going
yeah
it really is bad it was just an annoying
tool to deal with and my man's gets
dragon rush afterwards a great scramble
normal conversion there into the piccolo
as well he's got a lot of meter here oh
he's dead from
100 oh my goodness this man piccolo be
ali you've been to himself it's always
an all-star game yeah for sure for sure
one character down man like i swear it
always comes down to that i'm like
is this dead and then i realized oh yes
people have come on like
after the hills only gets mad stuff
yeah exactly right it doesn't stop you
sometimes the supers is where your life
begins to end this is where your life
begins to begin to end when you're
playing piccolo exactly
okay
all right
oh nice stuff there keeps himself in the
corner
look at this man i like a [ __ ]
really really looking good out here but
right now i'm trying to make something
happen here with this
jiren's shell and does so here she comes
that was so sick she definitely looks so
great when uh she is applying the
mix-ups and you see the air dash
utilization there tries to call the
great saiyan man but no assistance
tried it went for the command grabber
she was out of there she was not on the
ground nowhere to be seen and now this
should be able to kill here max spend
the two bars to do so on level three
okay just guarantees it once with their
we got some stuff when it comes to the
vanilla right so i i know i'm not bad at
him keeping him on board yeah yeah i'm
enjoying the video game for sure but
right now look at this look at this show
you have to deal with right now it is
not going to be a fun time
like at alphabet very smart riders he's
going to put up the barrier start
utilizing the broly zoning game that's
so good yeah i like the way he played
that
there's so many nasty mind games you can
play with that z broly in the piccolo
because of his command grab and dragon
rush it's just gross
okay wow buttons oh my goodness
square batons
sometimes you bet i'm not having to
guess right like i'm sick of trying to
deal with these mind games i'll play
some of my own facts
there we go
swinging
the run back we're getting it right now
all right
oh wait wait the counter
oh he actually got the hit as well
okay
a great sail man helping out
they heard me talking smack earlier yeah
what were you saying
doing a good job though he's going to
use that spark in your region all that
blue life invincible of course
there it is 6m with the sparking behind
it for the extended momentum
we'll get the kill on fidel and now
yomma
having to make this uh hold the camera
okay vanishes out as well
keeping the advantage any means
necessary
my goodness
do not get hit by this big body alien
because it's gonna hurt
yeah my man was running the jiren
infinite right there he's like are you
gonna test this block string he finally
did and it was at the wrong moment so
level three
that's it bro bro we got namekians we've
got aliens we have area 51 out here okay
the pressure
[Applause]
all right i don't know what it is about
jiren but he really likes to press
buttons when this character is on the
screen oh man shows no fear maybe he's
like gelling with the character oh no
he's dead he's dead
yeah that planet he's gone
the planet got smoked
yeah
oh my goodness bro z bully this
character is out here
so scary like you just can't contest
this character man like as he's never
out the game if you have this character
on your team you're never out of the
game ever
it's like that man
the limit break behind the two the extra
damage like it's always one of my
favorite things just because i like the
violence the destruction seeing people's
dreams get crushed and so when a broly
command grabs you into level three like
whether it be the air command grab like
we saw there the ground command like the
how much life gets deleted is just
absurd yeah yeah yeah absolutely man um
okay guys that was that was nice we got
the bangers just keep on coming oh i'm
enjoying this so far um we do have of
course the winners final is set now
fellas
let's just have a quick look at that
give you guys the breakdown of what's
gonna follow up here
tct versus mr jack ryan coming up of
course the winner of that will play
against yama our uh videl jiren player
we just saw
fall to z bully
and of course we're going to get to see
some more piccolo uh late lowdown and
loses bracket easy q takes on apology
man
yeah yeah we'll see well venet brings to
the table with that piccolo the tn as
well right a long time tn player so he's
definitely happy with the way this patch
has been going i haven't actually talked
to him about it but i assume he is but
first of course we are getting that tct
versus jake ryan match and yeah man of
course jake i think a little bit more
known in the scene now for being a
commentator but when i met him he was
just entering a wednesday night fights w
uh dbfc like everybody else you know so
it was definitely uh started as his
origins as a player like most of us do
when it comes to commentary i don't
really know any commentators that didn't
start as players oh of course
yeah jake is a part of that fold as well
and you can see he's still grinding and
now still takes a lot of pride in his
in-game skill on here he's got points as
you mentioned let's see if we can get
more
two right guys we'll get the names
updated in a moment there we go
all right here we go so jake ryan yet
this is his main team for sure does rock
the um
very very strong team i feel like this
is a very um
season uh season two season three team
actually the jake's rocking but still of
course super capable in this version you
know like these characters did not
really get nerfed in any way so
super super capable
yeah exactly right like basically it has
such good mix of you got the lock down
it's just a kick boo well man cct he's
playing a team that i think is one of
the most annoying things i've ever seen
perhaps team gohan uh is my man gogeta
and then not vegeta
yeah i mean i get it man i get it like
we don't really see much of go tanks
these days
but let's be honest like the character
yeah he's he's the only character in the
game that got directly nerfed
yeah like
you know so
i guess a lot of people dropping him i
think he's still very capable the ghost
oaky is still very very scary um and
yeah yeah really strong i feel i feel
like maybe you could argue jiren was
also directly enough but yeah i think
gotenk's got it really uh really bad
yeah gold things was definitely the
standout like we're going to make an
example out of you but yeah it's like
sit on the naughty step you know like
you have to take this
that was a good idea on the extension
didn't quite get it but still preventing
jake ryan from getting anything started
that's really been the tale so far in
this match like nobody's gotten a big
damage or significant like oaky but jake
ryan has just not been able to do either
nice reach up there from tct gonna get
ghost okay also here we go oh he
actually used the guard cancel but
unfortunately that ghost was there i
mean tcc couldn't extend but
a little bit of damage i mean that's one
of the things that hurt go tanks like
the ghost okay yeah it's super good but
the damage on it was decreased heavily
so
okay look at that and i like that the
neutral jump into the knockdown so he
doesn't keep the momentum gets better
space in on those ghosts
i was gonna say that was a great
recognition um
in that instance oh my goodness
behind with the jumbo
okay here we go
still feel like this character because
he's just one of the best man like the
reason why i thought basically just so
strong is he can do it all man he does
crazy damage he's got like great options
he can fight you so low he doesn't even
really need a partner most of the time
so
yeah he's decent it's just that his i
guess his neutral can become a bit
predictable uh from time to time but
with that jake ryan kid boo takes down
tct's goatees here we go
yeah really good stuff joe bryan
striking for his butt into his character
here use boulder's assist though tcp
found a window here to make something
happen and he does
yes
there we go knock down time level three
on the way gonna force jake's kid boot
into a guest for the game situation
what's it gonna be off into the dragon
rush he didn't take that and for that
he's going to lose kid
and the tct made sure he'd stay true to
that hard knockdown life right there
major brian guess guess wrong so back
all even in terms of characters
jake still has the advantage here so far
playing nice and slow trying to catch
tct flinching but not giving it to him
the falling button catches the dr
attempt there from tct and jake ryan in
a good position right now
don't know if you can close this out
though
yeah
wrench
can go to double level one the gala
again we'll put them on life support but
still up for now
you know we talked about vegeta's
options right and he has a lot of
different ways to hang in the air that
jump s right into the super dash just
really tct couldn't find the proper
anti-air timing yeah very hard to do so
yeah he's definitely got some really
good options nice reflect there from
jake and now paul's on the pressure once
again there it is
oh here we go pet the doggo and now full
combo time
we'll try to set up sharp again uh get
him to block some type of ground and mix
up behind android 21
take the r
all right here we go all loops okay
oh yeah he can't complete the combo
maybe maybe he wasn't sure about his um
extension there just went for a panic
vanish combo and of course that's not
going to be able to extend
yeah that's uh smart oh no i was going
to say smart stuff from jakey with
another ex overhead vanish still tct
staying alive but only to get
sniped out the air yep sniped out with
the key blast there that projectile and
now jake ryan looking to advance on the
bracket if he can win one more game and
uh you know that's going to do wonders
for him in terms of these world
championship points you know he's going
to stay in there he's going to get some
more juicy points as the bracket
progresses but he's got to get through
tct it's not over yet man
he's going to fight back as hard as he
can
yeah and jake is a you know he's a
emotion on his sleeve type of fella you
know and it translates to the game as
well so i know he's got a lot of nerves
that's why i think you saw that panic
vanish combo at the end there so with a
100 game lead that should let him relax
a little bit more so i'm looking for
even cleaner play here following that up
absolutely
okay
[Music]
we got hit with the go tanks being the
cs is paying off
let's see this has been mad work right
there clearing the screen giving them a
full combo
yeah i feel like those beams are still
very very useful
um but you know css took a hit overall
but they you know they still have their
uses
yeah i mean this is huge right here
though he got i ended up resulting in
jake ryan's sparkings and they want to
eat the next mix-up
just keep blasting them in the dome
right there staying on the same side
that meter pound the uh really making
sure kibbu didn't build to the bar he
needed to make that kill easy
okay look at this monster pressure it
feels like sometimes from tibu reflect
there gets the tagging to go tanks but
man he is still just holding all of this
pressure it's been unable to find his
turn
indeed the super dash finally gonna go
with the ex extension got both assists
back
and wow he's actually gonna go into the
vegeta instead yeah he wanted maybe the
more opponent mix i like that spark
instead
[Music]
james okay back
no okay jake's out of danger right there
those six s ki blasts
go tanks man could be so scary
definitely one of his best tools
oh
i'm dealing with the following
for that time but still put guard cancer
from tcp as soon as he saw that kid boo
says didn't want to eat the mix
right
should just get a simple knock down here
no sliding knock but still the vanish at
the corner once again jake and you're
right that that those vanish ships have
been getting him out of the corner and i
feel like tct needs to clock on you know
this man is pressing vanish on defense
you've got to be ready for that
yeah 100
right now tct that was a weird guard
cancel like you're reversing the side he
came in
he's got a four bars as well i gotta
imagine he oh actually not gonna go with
the hard knockdown
and then the goal hot assist for the
conversion so good
damn that
bro and look at that follow up as well
tct is cooking right now looking to fire
back up cylinders just needs to get
through this android 21.
but it's time it's time for my android
waifu to carry me
ryan oh the command grab that's how we
started off now tct he's gotta guess oh
no he trumped the combo though you
already used that one fam
good tech right there really aware being
able to defend successfully okay
all the way through and android 21 just
does it all so strong she
it's just so good like an incredibly
strong character i mean a solo it
doesn't matter like she's still so tough
to deal with
okay right now dct trying to hang on for
his dear life but jake ryan opened up
their key blasts
okay
bombos
all right so here we go this could be
tcp's chance
they're blocking out
oh and again jake ryan with the vanish
gets himself out the corner and he's
successfully oh he's out of there that's
gonna do it right there jake takes it
and man
this man was out there quickly bro he
was out
you know you identified the vanishes had
been costing him a lot right so i think
that's kind of what tilted him a little
bit towards the end there was the fact
that once again jake ryan was able to
get out of the corner via the vanish and
we saw he wasn't committed to anything
right there there's just no 2h to be
found that's unfortunate for him but
very fortunate for jake ryan the quest
for points continues it grows for a man
the commentator turned player well
player turned commentator back to player
you know there you go he's back there
he's doing work now guys uh so you know
shout outs to jake for holding it down
um tct going to bow out with a seventh
place finish you know he still gets
points um he does still get points at
the end of the day but you know he's not
going to be getting that the the juicy
numbers you know um
but yeah we're going to be getting on
with the next game in a moment fellas
but let's have a quick look at the
bracket real quick let's see if that's
uh
if that's updated for you guys at home
yes okay let's go
okay looking that way
my man jake ryan moves on face yoma in
the second
round of loser's side we gotta round out
that round one with easy q an apology
man coming up next
absolutely guys it's gonna be an
interesting one for sure man
apology man this is another guy that's
like been one of my favorite players to
watch for a very very long time man you
know he loves his one player games we
all know about that
this guy was
just the the guy man for that style of
play in uh
in marvel 3 so i'm always excited to
watch him play
really good mind for these games as well
you know breaks them down to a science
almost
100 yeah and apology man he's always
been about like never letting his
opponent play as you mentioned right and
he's brought that to this game and just
in general which is funny because
it didn't really strike me he doesn't
really strike me as that type of
personality because as you said he's
scientific like he's more scientific
than i expect a player like that to be
you know what i mean like
they're scientific in a way because
their setups are going to be like
planned out in a way where like it's
going to be later upon layer upon layer
but like he knows weird things about the
game that i don't expect someone like
that to know so yeah he's an interesting
fellow for sure a great mind for
fighting games yeah yeah he's he's he's
always um you know
been really if you talk to this guy you
know he's got a really good mind for it
you know he looks here in a really
interesting way it's one of the reasons
why we get him on on the dragon ball
fighters show to help us break down
these new characters because you know
he's super good at kind of understanding
um
you know what these characters are
trying to do um what makes them strong
you know the the tool sets and things
like that so yeah really really cool
stuff
yeah that that's a good point too like
he doesn't just look at characters
either he's very good at identifying
like what the game's about and like what
makes a character good within the game
system yeah so yeah i mean he i love him
every time you guys have them on for the
the previews and whatnot and we are
going to get to it ooh and again he's
rocking the blue goku this season as
well definitely a strong character
yeah i love this character he's really
really fun to watch like he's actually a
character i really want to learn like i
think it just looks so fun to play i
love the loops
thank you
yeah we've got them both
we'll get those names switch for you in
a moment moment fellas
man you talked about his versus game
history letting the assist do the heavy
lifting there yeah i doubt
yeah that's another reason why the blue
goku with that piccolo assist right the
two projectiles you can sneak in the
command grabs in between ezq not wanting
any of that sparking up here survive
nice got him with a second falling
overhead
this is it unfortunate right there okay
the spark up all right i see you
holiday man feeling the heat
and he's getting him getting himself a
good combo right now and a ton of meter
at that as well
and then we're going to slide knock down
trying to set up shocked over here
waiting to see if he'll bait him into
the super dash that was such good
impatient neutral apology man like he
was trying to beat him into it with a
piccolo assist and then once he got
close he actually countered it with his
other assist like my man's just so good
at the versus game oh yeah
okay that's gonna do it right here tien
more than enough damage on that level
one to close that out
the shotgun blast
oh yeah it's it's it's super super
damaging
if you able to utilize that the assist
from the ui oh and then beating out the
reflect expertly right there that should
be a dead tien here borrowing a drop
combo
oh no okay
all right sure bro why not why not yeah
send a message you know i don't need to
spend any bar i'm just going to reset
you for half a month
okay and again
dragon rush helping out man like these
these tournament dr's are doing the work
today
i always have all right it seems so much
more effective than tournament with all
the nerds and the pressure exactly
tournament vr that's why it's the same
all right
oh come on crab where you going
i like that
they really had to they really had to
improve them right
like the kebab grabs like they really
had to do it
they had to follow the trigger
people had to get opened up oh no we
tried the move it looked like a
perfectly timed media right there i
don't know what he tried it was up back
or what but hit grounded
that apology man still finds the tag
easy q is not really applying the
pressure was trying to give him some
space to do something but this wasn't
ready for the raw attack yeah but the
man with the ultra instinct right now
trying to make something happen
okay there it is
i guess they're here gonna get that
slice slideshow what happens
yeah
driving the combo old great cancel into
the two h though blowing up apology
man's guard cancel and that should be a
dead piccolo here
yeah pick what's done
for sure
final character for apology man it's
gonna be that blue goku
like another character that can still
definitely make it happen guys not gonna
be easy
got the two
oh my goodness
oh
man that did not pay off right there
that is a shame
that was ridiculous bro tried for the
guard cancer
ended up teleporting his teleport and
just blowing it up with the kick that
was
that was clean he came the other way man
he was looking the wrong side but yeah
that's gonna do it right there first
game up on the board apology man's gonna
have to turn this around if he wants to
take down ezq who's looking hungry right
now don't forget this is loser's bracket
guys you could be going out the
tournament
and look at that i already found the
crossover tried to get the optimal combo
left some damage on the table here
couldn't convert from that but he tried
to get antsy with the key blast blown up
for it
all right yep that's it
ah nice conversion easy to there okay
you're just helping out
oh my god for resets as well and the
pressure
man it's so hard to deal with this
okay nice yeah look most players are
playing out it's super fast like
definitely having
anything and like all blocks ready for
reset scenarios as well but apology man
put a stop to all that sparked up and we
know the damage piccolo outputs so yeah
great usage of the spark there and it
paid off big
definitely definitely
here we go
[Music]
okay that time he's ready then stopping
that neutral
just absolutely overriding okay oh he
waited i like that he said i've seen
that before bro
yeah there's no apology man having a
reads on the ultimate in instinct
options right now sparked up here but
he's still just blocking it out
okay
oh man
he was swinging all the reset as well
goes behind with a cross up and now
apology man is cooking
i think that's not he's dead he's dead
almost definitely you're gonna blow
through that sparking regen you're not
gonna have a chance at life my friend
piccolo to end it and that has just been
a classic way people been getting opened
up in dragon ball fighters for a while
right you're hitting the assist so you
use it to jump cancel and instant air
dash over to the other side when you're
not expecting it very smart
okay
[Music]
all right nice little pick up there from
apology man looks like he's back fully
in the driver's seat range
there we go this is this this is more
like the approaching man used to seeing
you know the guy that's just fully in
control just you know aware of every
situation
this is looking he's looking more like
himself this game
one hundred percent here i don't know if
he's got i mean
ac capable of killing here i mean maybe
but either way ezekiel's gonna have a
tough time after this combo getting back
into the game i want to put out the
double hell zone
actually is he actually dead tien he's
dead yeah she is wow son that was so
much damage bro i apology man this team
be deleting health bars
yeah man like
it's gotta be said though piccolo and
tien they're the cut that's that's the
cheat code right there that those guys
are saying they those dishing out mad
damage
ridiculous
it's a little hell's on with the
follow-up into the shotgun my pair
all right these fellas going back to the
lobby here might be a little team switch
here might just be seeing easy q just
trying to slow down the pace you know
stop that momentum because that was
all apology man in that game
it was all i was like oh i died nah we
gotta take a break
why did i die from there i i did you
know i'm outside
yeah
all right fellas let's go
back into it are you ready oh okay okay
yeah i look like he just wanted a
breather like i i would be in shock as
well you know
oh wow they actually decided to trade
and then both players call their assists
yeah this is a wow it seems like a very
evenly matched uh
just said here so far oh absolutely very
back and forth that's all about the end
of the day that's what we love about
fighting games it's those adaptations to
the players and uh you know just finding
out what your opponent wants to do and
countering it with your own strategy of
course oh yeah you can see there is an
adjustment right there from apology man
we saw that set up from ezq earlier
where he tech directly into what he
wanted that time apology man downtake
delayed it and avoided the setup
entirely and that um corner carry combo
from the police man was super good
because he's got a great position on
that easy q firing back trying to get
himself out this corner and does so oh
my goodness two mku lives
oh boy
that was a long distance look at the
damage
like
it's crazy
they knocked that on on the uh on the
super saiyan version but boy he's like
this guy never lost it
yeah exactly we'll go through the two
ramen fools throughout this our apology
man with a big hit here and because he's
in sparta he built so much meter we've
seen the damage alpha from piccolo
that's a dead character oh yeah is it
tien oh it didn't even need tien
wow there you go apology man looking
good right now
android 21 on the way in
yeah you know of course he wants that
blue goku back on point just because
he's so deadly with those assists
backing up nice command grabbed off from
easy cube
looking good we'll get the godot key if
he so pleases and he will go for it
indeed
here we go this is going to be rough to
deal with right now apology man in
trouble there's no spark to save him
here has to block olden does so
okay
i actually gotta empty out the whole
thing tried the two l ended up getting
blown up
all right
even steven's now two characters a piece
easy q with the slight advantage does
have more life and the spark available
my goodness you see the way you started
that off with two just jump up jump m
like it's such a pull until both of
these characters have great air normals
right right right
it's a great
point here from stardust falls in the
chat no knapper on approaching outside
napa a character that is definitely been
going in especially this weekend you
know we saw a city of mayhem won by a
napa player like napa one hour uk locals
here um yeah definitely a capable
character
you know hopefully we see the nap in the
future
level three right now
i'd definitely love to see that
character a bit more but here we go
polish your man right now watch your
dome in trouble now easy cue
yeah such delayed tag actually dodged
the child to blossom as well
barking though just blocked on the
ground still had to deal with the assist
because of it
all right there he is again reality
stone on this on the screen
oh my goodness
where you going
okay here we go
again level three
god oaky on the way donuts okay this
could be dangerous right now for apology
man
good block
oh yeah the empty low oh but he ended up
being blown up just once again and
letting all the abilities loose with the
fireball and then converting the assist
afterwards great stuff there was
too much on the screen to deal with
right there but here it is apology man's
signature character it is all about
piccolo
bigger facts
a man
who was who was once now has now become
one of the true piccolos for sure oh for
sure oh no wait what
maybe a polish man wasn't sure if that
would kill with the special beam so he
just went for a different situation
there but now he's gonna have to deal
with ultra instinct goku it's gonna be
tough
he got it
oh yeah you punched me
oh no oh
with this scramble still working out for
apology man here again though this is
still not dead fellas oh wait he might
be dead actually yeah i think he might
be fringe it's going to be close
dragon rush into the level three with
the limit break yep no not over yet like
oh what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do
[Music]
the pressure was too much my man wanted
out he was like i'm willing to risk the
vanish but a little bit done too early
in the super just punishing him on the
other end it's hard though man when
you're seeing that after everything
that's happened the comeback is imminent
you don't want it to be complete you're
just trying to find a way to stop it
stem the bleeding but i mean apology man
he's been in these situations before you
know what i'm saying that's why he is
who he is
exactly exactly apology man coming in
clutch there don't forget this guy is a
finalist for the for the uh for the
world tour you know this guy's been up
there you know on the big stage
uh you're doing it for a long time in
this game and of course multiple other
versus games as well
really strong performance and then great
composure being displayed right there
from apology man it has to be said
facts exactly right like my man down two
characters to one as you mentioned
though it was the signature the piccolo
is tried and true and i mean great stuff
pulling it out gonna be going on to the
quarterfinals of the loser decide to
face scientific who i'm pretty sure
those players have played at least a few
times against each other so gonna be
very familiar there and of course we got
yoma and jake ryan on the other side and
then zayn and alkovich in that winner's
final absolutely gonna be very very
exciting tournament from here on out
guys we are top six territory right now
but of course we will stay in the loser
side for the time being it's gonna be
yoma versus uh jake ryan i believe
coming up in a moment guys should be a
great one for sure man we'll see if jake
can continue his uh reign of terror
throughout the tournament here um
holding it down for for the commentators
man we don't want to see no we don't
want to see no no drops out here come on
i know you can do it jake but just be
unbiased of course you know janma was
looking super impressive really really
um strong team there i like the squad
man but baby the jiren the videl i'm
liking that
yeah definitely and we saw some glimpses
of some nasty videl stuff right like she
has
given her reckon ending or having an
option to kind of end in the air it
definitely presents opportunities to
really mix your opponent up heavily but
it requires a lot of setup and
conditioning that's kind of the the
drawback of adele right but if you can
start doing that and put your opponent
in these nasty setups i mean they're not
going to block it they ain't playing
against no videl that has that stuff you
know
and now it looks like jake ryan though
going with the tried and true on the
other side of course we talked about
this team the base vegeta is still so
good especially with that kid who locked
down this is behind it yeah it's really
really good for sure man like i mean in
this season you do have some more ways
out of that of course you've got like
for example the uh the
god cancer and vanish so there's a new
option that escapes that um
but yeah like you know it's still super
good at the end of the day and they just
have to spend two bars to do that to get
out if they want but here we go
knock down time
spends it early and it's so good no need
to get that crazy okay you get all the
stores back like it's just so good
yeah that's our yo ma he's gonna
sparking up actually chasing the jump
back from jake ryan though this could be
good oh just pressing buttons that are
not scared great sail man from the
rafters though
pressure now oh my goodness jake again
showing that vanish option on defense i
feel like these players need to kind of
be aware of this man a bit more
yeah definitely your model they're just
trying to get his bedell stuff off in
that instance what in the what was that
clash yo ma somehow it comes out on top
of it
okay yeah goes for the combo now there
we go
okay
oh nice and now it's going to be a very
ambiguous set up here let's see what
yama goes for left right where yeah all
the last second crusts up oh man that
was so nasty
i like that this is another reason why i
feel like uh super baby 2 is one of the
best character designs in the entire
game like there's so much
like creativity you have with this
character you love to see yes
that was a super sick late crossover
blown up jake ryan's reflect attempt as
well just
perfect stuff and he just looks so
stylish doing it definitely agree that
he is a one of my favorite characters in
the game
what's up here
it's a happy birthday oh he used the
wall bounce version though so
unfortunately bass vegeta gets out
dude that was a violent double axe
handle right there yeah fans didn't even
need to come from the top rope with that
one android 21 down no meters spent
let's go do it right there based on jake
ryan's final character coming in yoma
though with a full squad three
characters on deck
c assist connects oh my gosh you're in a
world of hurt now and that was a 2l
start so that's essentially a medium
star
oh true yeah i had the jiren too
level three here to get the max damage
on this situation and put jake in a
guest for the game scenario could be
curtains right now let's
see how on earth did you get that
that's what i'm saying you know finding
the cross over at that last sentence is
one more 2l for the road on jake ryan
one oh lead here for your marshall he is
looking a little solid out here guys
that was that was scary that that that
whole game right there
man
jake gonna have to really uh go back to
the drawing board on that one if i was
him maybe even take a little you know
trip to the lobby oh that's what he's
gonna do right here i respect it yeah i
respect it
same that is a very overwhelming team
easy to get lost in the sauce against
all the stuff that he saw there so i
like him taking a breather here
recompose himself before jumping back
into what could be a lot more nonsense
absolutely brother
okay are you ready we're going straight
back in of course jake this time oh we
got the gogeta four now okay kid
kid boo taking a break um go get super
saiyan 4
uh bass for gr android 21 this team
looking good
he's trying to get
onto the new metaphor for right now
oh man here we go
[Music]
so strong like i feel like this
character definitely
you know even if you don't build a team
around that level seven uh
you know the stores he's still just very
very solid great tool set
strong character overall
yeah exactly right i think he's
definitely way more than just his level
seven gimmick even though that is even
more than a gimmick i think it's
definitely in certain instances a very
strong tool in the game but yeah he's
got a good buttons in general very good
specials different ways to stagger the
pressure that's one of i think his
strong disabilities in this game oh
who has the dp option they end up
whiffing but whatever doesn't matter
sparking into a chase down here jake
ryan i also also like here against baby
you know character really does rely on a
lot of projectiles because you know
vegeta's got that lariat to get through
some of the projectiles and things like
that so as i'm saying this he's getting
absolutely cooked and he's gonna lose
the character actually so he's gonna go
one into one into level three and gogeta
four is no more
yeah the vanish guard cans are going to
result in the neutral returning and the
super saiyan 4 getting
just swinging it out work out but yoma
gets himself a little spot of trouble
there okay fidel gonna take this level
three shinnae let's see what the
follow-up's gonna be okay
goes low
oh my goodness bro
thanks bro for sure the meter penalty is
hefty though i'm gonna be able to build
to a bar just yet no extension with the
assist either oh still just out of range
tries for the swing
enough time to tag but the 2l blows it
up yeah the 2l blows up that's the
interesting one for sure but okay there
we go yoma
dale right now gets the hit
jake's vegeta
okay
jiren of course
been one of his main like security
blanket options right the vanish the
guard cancels just trying to reset back
to neutral i mean when you have 21 it's
a good spot to be
[Music]
i'm surprised that court right there
usually yeah we see the android 21 right
after i bounce off the super dash the
jump medium but instead the jiren oh and
then protecting the legs he was not
jake ryan here that's a big damage
starter but again not enough meter here
to get the kill yeah you know maybe even
the assist wouldn't have been very
useful there
okay all right though jake gets a clean
hit now
yeah it's definitely these these mans
are swinging for sure like it's it's
looking violent
all right
okay let's see what's going to be here
goes in front great one there from jake
and now he should
no i missed the rejump
oh
[Music]
this is what's made it so scrappy though
like they're also like the combos are
ending right before the characters die
and like there's barely any health left
and it's just swing swing
remaining for jake here i'm sure he
takes a big side it's all up to you
based vegeta let's go
come on jake
the entire commentary community is on
your back right now brother
come on man
from tyrant
brother across the globe
hell yeah
okay yoma right now although you know i
love me some super baby as well so oh no
he did not get the uh the slides that he
wanted there
yeah so lots of opponent mix here just
maybe we're gonna go with something safe
okay yeah following button
blowing them up for now hold the eex
rocket kick and he actually converted
but not for the kill oh no
he is trying to get that hit by any
means necessary by any means necessary
he is just swinging
all right
like it's sponsored by tesla with these
rockets bro what is going on
oh the success
what are you saying
all right again okay again tries it and
then he tries it again
he's looking forward he's trying to find
an open up these legs are flying
very safe though because he dies to one
right but dell dies to one like he knows
he's not in a scenario where he can feel
safe oh no
oh no and there it is so hard to be
ready for that man so many options to
look for but there jake ryan really oh
my goodness you want to talk about ex
moves bro i got you yes round star
record gonna do it right there for fidel
and joma advances on jake ryan with an
impressive performance today but bows up
with a fifth place
you always got to be aware of how your
play will affect your opponent's player
right like when you do a certain option
like sometimes your opponent is going to
be like that's a good option i should do
that right and we just saw a lot of the
advancing specials from jake got duffed
by the videl one at the end there so
just took a page out of jake's book and
beat him with it so that was good stuff
from yoma gonna be advancing here for
some more points dragon ball absolutely
we'll advance on so gg's right there
gonna get the bracket up in a moment
there we go
so yeah it will be yo my advanced on to
the losers semi-finals guys who gets
that top four position and with it a
nice chunk of points um guaranteed but
the next match is going to be an
absolute banger guys we've got
scientific versus apology man
damn it's definitely going to be a good
one
yeah it's going to be five
um
see if we can get another quick look at
these this these point breakdown
all the points
yeah just so we can have another little
reiteration of what these players are
fighting for today guys don't forget
this is a master challenge so
first place gets 200 points look how
much the points goes up man that top
four onwards you know you're looking a
lot better right there if you get the
dub
yeah exactly right and that is where
yoma is now yomo with the guaranteed top
four finish making it into loser semi so
guaranteed 70 points jake ryan going
down on that fifth place so he's gonna
be getting 45 points big ups to jake
here coming out yeah i mean that's big
man you can see that's third place for
the 10k online challenge events right so
these master challenge events if you
have the opportunity to answer them you
guys to make sure you do because you
cannot afford the points that could fall
by the wayside if you don't exactly
exactly you know and even even uh
top 16 you get points of course and if
you guys enter your uh
the community events as well you know
the more people that enter the more
points you're gonna get so
yeah the dojo system really coming in
clutch here for the fights community and
yeah hopefully we can uh see some more
regions represented in the uh world
championship towards the end of the
season
yes that would be amazing of course
dragon ball has always been a very
worldwide game there's been such great
talent from all over the globe and i
mean that's going to continue here right
that's why we're showing off so many
regions and we're going to have those
final four participants from the various
regions like brazil and australia i
believe was another one as well so yeah
there's going to be a bunch of
incredible talent at that finals and
here we go this is going to be a loser's
quarters apology man versus scientific
let's get it oh my goodness already
starting with our
okay
a big green assist there and look he's
gonna get so much damage on this man
character that a lot more people are
really seeing the power of these days
and he just fits so well on so many
teams i feel like he's got that kind of
like
season two gt vibe where he can be like
the glue that holds the team together
you know what i'm saying like he's
really sorry he's got decent assists
and yeah he's just a strong character
yeah exactly he just like it makes a
such good use of like every type of
assist too like it's just like he's
aided in neutral by it because of his
like strong specials and the stagger
pressure just makes like hoe and pulling
tools like that piccolo assist or
something very uh dangerous to deal with
definitely
okay
yes of course the meteor just like
dragging him out of the corner
scientific bro he is holding this down
look at this that's the character
dispense the ex chop there to do so an
apology man down to that tien
uh another signature character him for
him but man i don't know if he can make
this happen but anchor tien is
definitely a powerhouse like there's no
slapstick
oh yes 100 we've seen apology man
already not quite make a three character
come back where they're almost full life
bars but we've seen a comeback already
in the books from him today of course
his character's damage output is wild he
just needs a proper starter and he can
make it bleed real quick try for the
dragon rush but scientific well aware
reaction right there from scientific
policy man gets to knock down there with
the
button
all right i see i see you scientific he
has been looking just clinical this game
jeez
yeah exactly
stayed in control and it's not let
apology man play we're going to get
another knock down here just setting up
shop with the meteor we're expecting the
reflect recovering in time from that 5h
as well and then just air with punishing
apology man i mean you can tell these
guys have played a bit i think apology
man really does favor the air game a lot
he really likes to look for that and
kind of predict when his opponents jump
and try to get a step ahead on them and
scientific waited that out and just
punished him instead that was expert
knowledge right there about who he's
playing against that was yes that was
extremely extremely solid play right
there man
bro this guy looking sick like you can
see the the similar the similar teams
but brothers the styles the way that
scientific just kind of just played you
know he just chilled he just played like
a like a bait-and-switch game he was
just waiting for apology man to make the
mistakes and just punish him accordingly
overhead there no
interesting
apology man in my experience is very
good at playing against aggressive
players like he's a good at weathering
the storm and kind of finding the holes
in your game he's like a counter puncher
like a boxing you know so scientific i
think does a a good job of kind of
waiting it out and playing patient
enough to throw him off
okay and that i think is enough oh of
course it's enough man it's when you got
tien it's always just like yeah and you
get that little bit extra juice
so that's going to be the kill right
there um man first character goes down
for a polish man the blue goku man
scientific is just continuing that
momentum from the first game
yeah that's rough for apology man bro he
is still not in three out of five
territory so this could be his dragon
ball fighter's life
long distance from the beam but yeah i
can't quite
nice one
once again everything's just paying off
for scientific man apology management
unable to get anything going here
okay
version of that vanish to blow up the
hell zone very smart yeah good choice
for sure
oh man did you see that hit box on that
this guy man this is the fingernails i'm
telling you bro jump light it's just
nasty
[Music]
got the batty fingernails the long
joints
yeah and there we go that's going to do
it
boom what did you man stays alive there
it takes down that piccolo that's been
just running right that could be the
start of something bigger
okay
again you can see these players are just
never wanting to deal with those meteor
mix-ups but it doesn't matter hold you
back not [ __ ] his dome opened up here
lots of meter being built via the spark
wow the rising jump l actually still
caught the raw
[Music]
attacks apology man maneuvering just out
of the space
right here oh
it wasn't confirmed it wasn't actually
going with the auto combo but it doesn't
matter didn't have any more meter to
further convert
okay
what that super dash was cursed did you
see that
oh yeah
damn
wow okay
[Music]
[Music]
man apology man has the tien available
we talked about the damage output that
he's capable of
okay level three on the way now let's
see if he can get this hit just
oh chelsea no way he whiffed
oh
how could you do him like this bro the
freeze frame with like the leg in the
air gave you like false hope it gave me
false hope
and then he just landed
that hurts man
that hurts for sure like
there's nothing else to say like he just
it just didn't go that it didn't go his
way man charles who did not come in
clutch right there um no but guys
before
i mean let's take a quick look at the
bracket real quick because we got top
four set
yes
before we've arrived of course that will
be um apology man going out the
tournament guys the fifth place finish
as well scientific will advance on
but before we get into this top four
guys we are going to um
i mean that's that's incorrect sorry
yeah apology man did not win apology man
lost so uh scientific won that one so
it's gonna be yoma versus scientific in
the loser semi-finals yes thank you very
much um and then of course
uh zane versus alikovic in the winner's
side guys so yeah it should be very
interesting but before we get into this
top four we are going to take a little
five minute break so
you know
you know grab grab some snacks grab a
drink whatever you want to do um and
we'll be back with some more dragon ball
fighters action in just five minutes
time guys so don't go anywhere we'll see
you very very soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right guys we are back thank you for
joining us here for the dragon ball
fighterz world championship kickoff
event here with uh north america west of
course tyron and ringett the hold it
down and man i'm ready for this top four
we gonna get it
yes indeed top four you know how we
begin top fours here in the fgc that's
going to be with winners finals which is
going to be zane versus alkovich and
we've already seen both of these players
taking down some heavy hitters in the
winter semis to get to this point in the
first place they're gonna be guaranteed
some fat points right top three
guarantee for both of these players so
at least a hundred points to their name
that is a good day at the office but you
know they want that full 200 that comes
with first place
oh yeah for sure
you know that's where it really really
starts to uh increase your chances of
qualifying for the world championship
finals so
at the regional phones i should say so
we're gonna get into it right now guys
the players are ready to go um
so let's get into this one man can be
excited we've got some go
some uh goku black on the screen for a
second
of course it's gonna be the zamasu for
zayn let's go
i was getting excited for a second bro i
saw him i was like oh wait really nah
the mix starts even in the cinematics oh
my speaking of mix how did he end up
there there's no better word to use than
mix right there
that was nasty
nice block on the law here occupation of
the storm but blocking can only get you
so far against the dragon rush
absolutely okay there we go the orbs the
pressure right there as well oh here he
comes
the bully himself
trying to put somebody in the locker oh
yeah very very nasty character
this guy's going in
oh god cancel there
okay it's gonna get out for now but may
has that headstone on that it's just
allowed for the easy follow-up
yes guys this is a winner's final match
so it's three out of five
all right my name
no
yep level three on the way
okay the reflect orbs still on the board
there yeah that was uh
scary scary to have that right there
with beerus man it's definitely a good
option
against the character like broly with
those massive buttons you know
yeah that clap that like it made him
still block after the reflect i couldn't
believe bears was still in range like i
was like just a super good sequence yeah
and 6m overhead with the assist
follow-up good stuff from zayn right
here isn't it funny
like we're like year four right now with
this this game's life span or whatever
but man the fact that
six and with assist is still
clocking people like that like this
sometimes simple is best range let's be
honest
it is man for sure it's just one of
those options that has remained good and
i know we're playing online right now
but i've still seen that work offline to
this day you know what i'm saying france
versus usa people got clocked by 6m
overhead oh yeah it's going to work for
sure like it's it's always been a great
option
oh man that's awesome yeah got the hit
butt okay i like a [ __ ] now trying to
just get a little bit of damage on the
board not going to be a ton here with
the key blasting to the vanish but still
good situation afterwards with piccolo
yeah exactly utilizing the new z change
situation bring piccolo in kind of get a
better
follow-up but still oh the elbow dodging
this wrong tag was wow
damn
all right
okay and again that full screen assist
wow no conversion unfortunately that
didn't have any bar to get the vanish
though he's got plenty of bar that's not
a problem he's got
l zone after the table oh just eats it
yeah what happened there i'm not sure
what zayn tried
whoa
wow reach for the skies right there
yep the spark up okay super dash
connects gets the hit here ex shoulder
follow up now
you're gonna waste that sparking time
get a combo double reflect though
doesn't even have the situation i like
that defensive style from alcovich
yeah oh look at that using the assist to
get the guaranteed oh you saw the guard
cancel yeah we saw it in the cinematic
he was mashing that
got himself out of danger good stuff
maybe a missed time there okay but here
we go
dragon rush as well
oh my goodness what a block in the empty
low on the other side yeah that was a
sick blow man
had to do it
and then he got the raw tag in my man
alcove that was a tough storm to weather
but he made it through like a soldier
yeah he wasn't about sitting there again
come on grab he wasn't about it oh and
again dash is up on him
man this is looking terrible for
alikovich right now zane in control
should be able to get this kill easily
yep
all right yeah i was going to launch
into about how i'm glad he went to build
his third bar so he can get the kills
didn't need it
okay
and again sets out the orb here i like
if it's trying to just stay alive with
this piccolo
this has been the piccolo bracket bro
we've seen so many of him so much of him
lately here we go though
and then scuffing the jays the tree bark
14 shout outs to the ice
oh that's it
bruv
that was all zayn
yes this guy was
it was a win
this guy was just like on on fire the
entire match i don't think we saw like
one
dominant string of offense from
alakovich it was all zane bro
no and i mean i think he's picking up
right where we saw him in winter semis
like this team is very control heavy and
it's hard i think if you don't have
experience against this and i don't
really know anybody that runs like
zamasu beerus like this so because of
that it's rough i don't know maybe sonic
at a point did but i don't know about
what they play nowadays yeah yeah yeah
uh
over here we have gropis plays a a very
strong uh zamasu beerus and baby i
believe i think he's switching up though
he's like
he plays like ten characters so it's
like but yeah i feel like it's
definitely a solid shell for sure man
yeah it just offers so many ways to kind
of like lock down the opponent and
present things that they have to deal
with obstacles and right now alkavic
maneuvering through the core so much
better than he did that first game yeah
i mean i was about to say can we talk
about this red on zamasu's life bar
right there that was insane that combo
did so much damage
very natural
then bro blue goku is just
this character is so damn hard
all right hurts that hard
this guy doing like 6k before supers
with ease like man it's kind of
ridiculous
okay
i like a [ __ ] fighting back this game
by the way look at this
yeah just a quick side switch as well
put them back into the corner oh yeah
he's blown up zayn tried to make his way
out i don't know
what but could have taken out of the
combo you've seen it turn blue like that
yeah martin's name had his mind on other
things
exactly it's blue it wasn't true but man
like uh
alex will take that all day
yeah that's that's on zane that's not
his fault you know what i'm saying
that's not alex he's full he's like
you messed up brother
it's not my responsibility
here we go full combo time
yeah i'm just gonna chop him ex version
spark up here i respect it man might not
get another chance to do it if you don't
use it there so
yeah oh this is huge actually
uh yeah you can meet your pet over here
but it's already gone yeah it comes back
oh the challenge again to jump the
fingernails bro big green
bro they're so good jump light is insane
they've only grown as the seasons have
they haven't gotten close that's
something that hasn't been
all right
okay
man look at this just trying right here
zayn he's trying not to get overzealous
right not to give me anything free does
he manage to find that and he's got a
lot of bar this time around so he could
start the level three games if he wants
but no
oh
no zayn i feel like zayn had a ton of
drops this game alikovic is gonna spark
up just to guarantee his option there we
go he don't even need to follow up there
the level one does it man he's looking
so that is a great way to fire back for
sure okay so we're going to be going
back in uh in a moment i believe let's
see yeah it could be some issues right
maybe trying to reset the
connection a little bit because of the
drop so yeah definitely zayn and
alkavich trying to find their footing
but zayn i mean it really the story of
that second game was the fact that
alcovich was able to kill that zamasu
right out the gate right like the fact
that he deleted the point character
really never let zayn get his footing
back
yeah just i just remade the lobby guys
just to make sure because you know how
like sometimes it can cause problems and
stuff but okay yeah so we are still 1-1
um
no problem and it's first of three now
too so i was essentially back to two out
of three territory so nobody's gonna be
going out into the loser's side after
this next match but the pressure is
beginning to build they don't got too
many left
absolutely absolutely
okay guys we are gonna get that match
for you
just a moment um but yeah thank you so
much for joining us everybody here on
twitch.tv dragon ball fight is to help
us kick off the world championship
season uh of course we are in the online
tenkaichi uh challenge phase so it's all
about the online points for the next uh
for the next two months and then of
course you know we're gonna have um
we're gonna move up to december that's
where the regional fires are gonna take
place where all the uh warriors that
qualified are gonna be thrown down
offline it's gonna be super exciting man
i can't wait to see that offline
environment back again man that they uh
the usa and france event was like that
was a taster of what's to come you know
what i'm saying
yeah and it's gonna be christmas time
indeed right like pretty much the first
three weekends of december are gonna
have offline dragon ball events we
couldn't have asked for a better holiday
season so i can't wait to get to there
exactly man exactly it's definitely
going to be the early christmas present
like you said
and now saying alphabets are going back
at it again it's going to be one up oh
now kavinsky wanted out of that pressure
early with the reflect but zane read it
like a book
okay
orbs right there wow but it's alakovich
that turns the tables in the in the
right way there knocked down
okay oh no follow up that's a shame bro
it's all a bit about this corner this
game these guys don't want to leave
oh yeah for real they're gonna fight for
the real estate whose territory will
belong to looks like zayn's for now my
man's gonna be able to delete the rest
of his blue gold
yeah if you go through out of there for
sure
man zane with a solid round start there
luke goku goes down quickly
that was definitely like it was like san
andreas they were fighting for the
corner which color wasn't going to turn
all right
challenge it down
[Music]
okay and you've got me so
man you gotta be just so careful when
that that bull that's the bully assist
is there bro he just wipes out the whole
screen
yeah
it's nice and very annoying
oh the low lord beerus
clear is going off right now man alchemy
just couldn't find the defense really
got lost then what else was trying to do
oh again this was the empty low
lord beerus with the twinkle toes bro
you got to be careful
yes sir oh filled in all the bar he
could ask for as well yeah as long as he
completes this is another dead character
oh it's more than enough man look at
this boom
get him out of there
zamasu as well getting involved and now
man z bully comes in but let's be honest
this character with spark and six bars
it's he's not at this fight
yeah for sure i think against this team
is gonna be especially hard but the fact
that he has the sparks seven bars limit
break he is definitely still in this and
just a few command grabs away honestly
oh yeah no absolutely dude
you know in a character like zamasu that
likes to float around as well you can
get snatched really yes
we saw that we saw that from alkavich
already right the anti-air into a level
three but right now he's still gotta
find oh the right hit oh no ended up
reflecting and just whiffing
yeah he was trying to reflect but it did
not pay off for him and now there we go
blades of judgement
sets it up
yet they are knocked down
another one okay just for the okie now
all goes low
oh
so hard to deal with and that is gonna
do it right there for zayn 2-1 lead in
this set guys but it's not over yet like
we said it's a winner's final set so
it's three out of five
to take it
and i i really love the fact that zayn
was just like he saw the first reflect
and then he just did another jump right
he like didn't commit to anything he
didn't press a button with zamasu to get
caught in the reflex so he gets pushed
away he was very smart very patiently
and already i love that too oh chase
another blue goku back to back dashes
yeah man zayn is really feeling it yeah
he's looking good like
and this is i feel like it's always he's
been setting the pace and it's always
been up to alikovic to really just like
match his his pace you know and just
adapt to zayn's gameplay
yeah for sure
nance hasn't really gotten to impose his
will at all it's all been reactionary
yeah exactly i mean that's kind of what
zayn's team is designed to do though
with this bear beerus the zamasu it's
very hard i think to control the pace
against this team yeah
for sure dude okay there we go oh my
goodness you get so much time to convert
off of that
yeah i was big here and we saw oh come
on grab and that's what led alkavich to
victory in that w he did take getting
rid of the zamasu nice and early yeah
very very clean
okay
again why the hell not
oh my goodness he is bullying his way in
there with the blue goku so much so zayn
feels the need to pop spark
okay here we go all dp's himself out of
danger i guess a full extension here
with that spark
look at this
okay doesn't set up just keeps the
pressure going
okay at this time look how much blue
life he's getting back that was a
brilliant spark
yeah that's exactly why he did it in
that scenario right he's like all right
all this damage i took was a dp start so
i can get all this life back but right
now zayn finds another hit plenty of bar
put him in the level three hard
knockdown situation what's the follow-up
gonna be let's find out is it gonna be
orbs yes it is ex time goes low again
and i feel like that beerus low has been
at the tail of the tape it has been
opening alikovic so many times
100 percent man has been paying
dividends all that investment has been
giving him more and more money back and
right now zane bringing in the android
21 i like that a little bit more of a
healthy character and she's just such a
monster and neutral blowing up the
reflective tip and another great
conversion utilizing the assist yep he's
looking super good right now
okay zayn does use that vanish there
just to get that corner position knocked
down time
okay
and that fires straight back fight it
sounds like the broly assist just gets
that screen control back goes back to
the neutral
one but it's back though here we go
there it is they just cleans out the
screen bro
yeah this one oh great reaction with the
reflect right there all right this is
massive
will not be able to get the kill but
it's all about the situation
yep level three gets the oaky on this
the god oaky and all the stores will be
back
how does alphabets respond to this here
those blocks successfully reflects
afterwards gets out of the okie for now
the middle of a good block yeah that was
really really clutch right there okay
all the dunk and then the has to use
that little
bit of get that a little bit of extra
damage with the vanish good stuff for
zayn and now it's all up to this map
alikovic and he he's
like it still looks pretty even to me
ringed i'm not gonna lie oh 100 100 like
full life broly six bars on deck to zayn
not having any is as even as they could
get honestly yeah yeah yeah
hold the challenge
afterwards oh the cross up oh my
goodness bro her cross up is just so
crazy
yeah and great awareness from zayn right
there jumping out of the command grab
and then taking advantage of the jump
out and dashing afterwards yeah
a big hurd box character like broadly as
well to deal with them cross-ups it can
be extra difficult sometimes but there
we go great take on the dragon rush
alikovic staying alive in this oh no oh
yeah oh no what happened
oh no
all right fellas we're going to get that
back sword
wait i think the players might still be
playing right i think so i think the
players still might be playing it says
this i think
go ahead
it says they're still in in the battle
so we're gonna we're gonna have to uh
wait for the the result on that one
but yeah hopefully
hopefully their game went fine you know
i'm saying we can get the result quickly
i think
right there at the end alkavich was
trying to like after he backed that she
got hit by the super dash i think he was
trying to squeeze out like the anti-air
command grant yeah yeah i think that's
most likely what he has been looking for
right that's always one of the key
factors for the comebacks with z bully
yeah but yeah man
it's a close set i don't know i want to
see how it plays out like honestly it
could it could uh go either way like
like the way that one before it cut off
i mean i'm hoping it's not like a crash
like like if one of the players had like
a game crash or something like that i'm
hoping it's nothing like that
yeah
um
but yeah that's uh momentarily i'm sure
okay so yeah we're gonna have to wait
for the result on that one guys but
um yeah we can check the bracket again
actually
real quick
just while we're waiting for the players
to finish up their match because it
looks like they are still in the uh in
battle so
yeah i mean we're still in the winner's
final side guys zane that did have the
lead before um there were the uh issues
there the technical issues
and of course like you said i mean
alikovic could fire back with that
zebrally we don't know what's gonna
happen in that set we'll find out in a
second but
yeah it looks like the
indeed yeah they're still playing as you
can see
okay okay okay
like going at it their game stayed
you know in which is the most important
thing to be quite honest yeah yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying like yeah as long
as long as they're playing the players
don't get the play
yeah okay and of course like you know
like the the the red bars on the
connection there
it's because i'm halfway i'm halfway
around the world i'm the host for the
lobby it doesn't it doesn't affect the
players game you know what i'm saying um
but yeah like that should be they should
their game should still be running crisp
it looks like
but yeah yeah
but of course this is just the very
first event when it comes to the
tenkaichi online master challenges and
beyond right there's gonna be one for
the usa east coast as well i think
there's gonna be four regions in europe
as well they're gonna have different
type of events that qualify you for and
then the community events as well that
we saw on that are gonna be going
on and i have a reward systems based on
entrance right the amount of points
you're going to be able to accumulate is
going to be dependent on how many
entrants you get for those community
events so if you're going to be a part
of those you're going to be entering if
you're going to be running them make
sure you encourage as many people as
possible to get in on the points so the
upper echelon those people that win can
actually you know have a significant
chunk go towards qualifying for those
regional events and there's plenty of
regional events coming up as well like
tyrion said earlier once we get to
december bruh once we get to december
those weekends are going to be dragon
ball field we got europe japan usa all
with offline events gonna be a beautiful
thing yeah man i'm actually really
looking forward to that for sure but um
yeah let me just get up on the screen
for you guys there we go yeah so you can
see there so that's the plan for the
upcoming the the regional finals guys
that's all offline like december is
going to be a great month
but yeah look at that it is literally
like start of december like fourth and
fifth and going all the way to like the
week before christmas so it is gonna be
sick yeah yeah exactly for sure guys
don't forget you can do x making my uh
bracket in the chat as well guys to
follow along with the bracket at home um
but yeah we did just have a little lobby
hiccup there guys which unfortunately
kicked uh kicked the the spectator
from that um i'm gonna actually let me
just change the settings in the lobby
actually so that
because i know that if you set the lobby
to um
to uh no rematch
this kind of thing is less likely to
happen so let me do that actually real
quick but yeah thanks so much everybody
for tuning in and sticking with us guys
yes yes
yeah this is uh just the first stop usa
west we had a lot of players come out
already we saw big ups to jake ryan
apology man got some points of course
but yeah man we still see zayn looking
super good alkavich also and both our
winners finals participants looking very
strong i want to see yeah if zayn
manages to clutch this out he is looking
kind of monstrous i really like his team
composition a lot so these players just
in general i think that's one of the the
big things about this season of dragon
ball right i think that's one of the big
things that people touted about france
like their team compositions are just
out of this world and nobody knows what
to do at least the usa doesn't know what
to do about them and uh yeah i think
that's just going to continue with the
creativity that these players are
exhibiting yeah yeah like it's like the
the
unique composures like you said is
definitely there you know i i love to
see that honestly like they
they showed that like a lot of
characters
that a lot of people didn't think were
viable are super viable you know looking
at characters like i don't know like
vegito and
uh
gogeta iv for example you know like i
mean
so i mean i feel like some people kind
of
were clued up to go get four to begin
with like he definitely has some crazy
team compositions uh players like
reynold was already doing absolute
just
bro that guy is one of one of my
favorites to watch for sure he has got
some nasty stuff with that character
yeah
reynold is definitely one of those
constructed uniquely fellows right i
always talk about how he is like i think
a lot of fighting game players ideal
selves you know like if you could play
how you would ideally want to play at
all times i think a lot of people would
want to be reynolds to be quite honest
with you like he just has like a great
balance of disrespect while still like
just being mad sick himself like i don't
know it's it's super cool exactly man
for sure um all right guys so we're just
getting the result in there so they i
don't think the players were aware that
like the spectator got kicked so yeah i
think they did play the complete set so
unfortunately
we're not going to see that one but
we're going to find out who won that one
in just a second guys bear with us okay
and again do apologize entirely for that
one uh sometimes these things happen out
of our control of course
you know i wanted to i wanted to watch
the matches as much as you guys so
yeah 100 that does mean though
scientific made that zebrally come back
yeah
yeah yeah
uh okay okay who won
man oh
zayn zayn looked like such in control to
me but i mean if scientific ended up
winning i wouldn't be super or not
scientific excuse me um alkavich
but did we get a result sorry zayn
because zayn won that one same one oh
okay okay okay so he managed to pull out
the side okay all right guys both of
those players look very strong so but
zayn zayn is looking good yeah confirmed
guys zane won the set so he will be
moving on to the grand finals
um
to hold it down of course that's a big
big advantage to have to be in the
grandfather's winner's side um
but yeah i have uh
so yeah i have i've disabled the rematch
in the lobby now guys like
it's just to make to try and make sure
it doesn't happen again of course you
know things can happen out of our
control
um but yeah zane took that set guys so
he will be advancing on there we go we
can see it okay
yes sir
zayn i'm gonna take his spot in grand
finals and as you said if you're
unfamiliar with the way the double
elimination bracket works that means he
is going to have winners advantage
essentially the person who gets into
grand finals from the loser side he's
gonna have to beat him three games
before he even gets a chance at taking
the first place right if they beat zaina
three games before zangie's the three
games that means we are all back to zero
zero and another set is going to be
played represented by that gf reset box
there you see on the screen now of
course
and okay we do have the fellas ready for
the next match guys of course it's gonna
be the losers semi finals now yoma
versus scientific
and let's see who's going to get that
but of course guys this is not a three
out of five game this is still two out
of three because it's not a finals match
yeah but back to the semi finals back to
the two out of three land yeah exactly
we'll see you omar and scientific the
pressure will be ramped up a little bit
here of course playing for the points
guaranteed top four position but that
third place gets that hundred points
right you get into the triple digit club
if you're able to get that top three so
exactly you know these players are going
to be fighting scratch and clawing for
it exactly that's where it becomes super
super important to really bring your a
game you know you want to be holding it
down and trying to go for those big
points because if you want to represent
your region at the regional finals man
you wanna you wanna you wanna play you
wanna get to offline you're gonna have
to bring it so
let's get it man
yeah man definitely i don't know all
these players are looking to do so right
there's a lot of motivation i think a
lot of fire has been ignited uh amongst
dragon ball players after that usa
versus france exhibition yes and then
there's more promise of offline to come
right so i think a lot of players right
now are definitely feeling the
motivation that they've been lacking for
a while
yeah yeah yeah it was actually super
cool to see that and it was cool to talk
to a lot of the guys that maybe didn't
get a chance to play a lot of offline
like i was talking to um to hook and to
sage and those guys were like yeah this
is
this is like you know this is exactly
what we needed you know to get the fires
burning these guys want to hold it down
now so
yep let's go we're gonna have the next
match guys scientific versus yoma let's
go
all right all right scientifically gonna
be on that first player's side once
again
yo ma bringing some dirty stuff to the
table as well with avidel jiren we saw
earlier
yeah great reflect on the tien assist
right there and then challenging on the
incident super smart
long distance on that and wow the space
ended up the letting scientifically get
that forbidden starter the first auto
combo sequence whiffing but the second
hit of course connecting
okay oh
all right
okay
here we got the extenders
okay there we go straight into the video
there there we go it does not me we saw
him this time that earlier on in the
tournament but this time gets the clean
hit let's go yoma with a big chunk of
red on piccolo there
spark up
on the ground wow
i like the little sequence there yeah
get himself a guaranteed situation good
stuff
scientific yeah you definitely end up
making that sparkling pay off you see he
gets to hit on videl sending up again
and your
in uh responding in kind
fantastic a challenge good timing on
that one from yoma but man scientific is
out of danger
okay
wow all right wow did you i can't be
that hit what the hell yeah
it's crazy
now scientific oh my goodness we've seen
the abilities the capabilities of my man
super saiyan 4 gogeta here it's gonna be
close though i know that combo is gonna
be a little bit more extended from there
but yeah i don't think it's dead even
even with tien i don't think that's
gonna do it
oh how could i doubt the man the last
hit
bro
that was crazy yeah i can't believe that
killed actually that was that was nice
oh
teleported into the sky for the counter
my mans cannot escape
2l look at that man that's going to be
medium starter essentially it's going to
be a ton of damage on the board going to
get that baby assist off as well
probably just need one bar on this
wow look at that
again your mouth doing such a great job
really maximizing his damage on every
single hit
and you were correct one bar all that
was necessary there yeah
picks up off the piccolo once again
we've seen that time and time again
wow the raw tag connects now and then
here we go
yeah end up getting caught off guard at
the last second by the wrong tag
level three for the setup here your mom
see if he gets a little
a little shenanigan heavy oh a little
bit there whoa he actually
punished it like he did bro
that was that was great i don't know if
that's what he wanted but it paid off
perfectly well for yoma
i don't know what that specifically was
mad anime bro like he just dumped him
with this well and then this time the
jump light had the auto combo and a
follow it up great stuff from yamaha
right there seal in the first game yeah
looking really solid for sure man it is
all up the scientific now to really turn
this around bring this back
very very very solid match there
yeah great stuff from your mom man
really i've been loving the jiren the
super baby the veda everybody you know
and that's another thing with this game
being out for a while now is the fact
that these players have been
used to these characters they've been
able to kind of explore these nuanced
situations and kind of
bring out the just squeeze out the juice
of these characters that take a little
bit more time than these
obvious top tiers you know exactly
exactly yeah it's really really nice to
see for sure and um i love seeing people
play you know the characters that we
don't get to see a whole bunch of i
think jiren is super capable this patch
by the way i think that he is very very
strong man um very much agreed
well let's check this one out straight
back in guys second game of the losers
semifinals oh come on grab city where
you
i like that another great scientific
establishing it early yeah and you can
see that uh the way that scientific
plays oh here we go ex dunk oh no
piccolo dropped out
the way that scientific plays gojira
he never goes i feel like he never goes
for levels he just uses the character
it's just as a
solid package you know doesn't have to
rely on that
exactly
okay
arc up there from yoma so much blue
light coming back really really good
time to spark and man gets a straight
light this is going to be a big damage
combo because that was pre-sparked
and yeah he built so much meter with
that sequence right there yeah the spin
sequence the quarter circle back s and
now he does not get the crosstalk looked
like he was going to get him for a
second yeah he wanted it but
unfortunately he did not pay off for him
still though you know that it's still
good oaky on there but this doesn't get
the left right
scientific doing a good job there
sparked up and he's been able to turn
the tides a couple of times once he does
get the spark on the table
throwing up that raw tack of town
beautiful usage of the assist exactly
really really nice okay scientific now
trying to make some kind of a comeback
now there we go there's no spark
available for either player so you've
got to play honest games now only
all reflect into the parry that was so
good look how much damage he got
oh my goodness yeah that perry alone
took off a huge chunk oh try to hit him
with one of his own
oh he landed and waited that was so
small
great discipline from scientific right
there and i mean he ended up blowing up
the assist too so he really found that
window right where harry was done right
before the assist clutched it out yeah
that that jiren parry did take a hit
this patch you know it did get toned
down ever so slightly
didn't even get to see active there
okay here we go
all 2m connects and this is gonna be so
much damage
yeah yeah plenty of meter as well so
he's going to do hurt immensely
yeah pressure now okay
yo
tag the piccolo for a little bit of
damage here
back into the corner and doesn't quite
blow up the car cancel oh no
yeah
and then the follow-up right there
scientific cooking
what way to fight back by the way like
he's showing him himself
to be fully capable that first game i
wasn't so sure up against yoma but man
like
what a way to fire back
definitely found his footing was a lot
more comfortable here yo ma down to just
a baby oh my goodness yeah with the
piccolo assist you're looking for a way
out and it's real tough to find that
exit
yeah i'm gonna get level one here
bring him to the corner i'd be there
right
pushing all the way back that's gonna be
a lot of ways yeah he's done yeah level
two oh my goodness he's dead wrench
jesus oh yeah
100 once again we see piccolo with tien
if they're lacking anything it's not
damaged that is for damn sure so 1-1
here and i lose the semis and again this
is our last two out of three set as well
so next match wins gets into that triple
digit territory for the points and a
shot at grand finals exactly you know
that's where it gets juicy like we said
triple digit points so important here um
let's see if there's gonna be a team
switch no we are gonna go straight back
in of course the rematch is off
so we do not well we have minimal uh a
lot of issues there good stuff
um to these players and man this is
gonna be an exciting one for sure i mean
right now it's anyone's game it's one
one who knows
exactly man both of these players have
shown up more than capable of kind of
converting and then taking control of
the match heavily right now scientific
he's the one that strikes first blood
see how much momentum he can take
right there you go
oh bro that super dash was illegal
my goodness yeah i feel like scientific
mixed himself up with it because of that
okay there we go come on grab there
man commenting in the clutch here oh
stomp his head out yeah buy system oh
you got a 2h like that i got one too
legit looked like a mirror in the
animation yeah i love that 2h
okay
all right great situation once again
okay extension with the gunpowder no he
missed it oh man that i think that would
have been close as well
yo scientific he's staying ready though
you gotta get ready if you stay ready
very meaty jumping dragon rushed
afterwards just really stuck him yep
okay yeah and then he will need the yeah
does need the piccolo
even though turns the powerhouse of this
the damage department the super still
gonna need big ring to back him up okay
last two characters here for yoma this
is his last chance
yeah but for some reason right
scientific he had that seven bars at the
start of that combo so you can see even
after this using vanish and the hell
zone still got two bars to go that's
going to be more than enough to kill off
yoma if he so chooses to directly into
the super saiyan 4 gogeta and the whiffs
yeah not sure what happened there maybe
he wasn't sure about the the super
timing on that
but yeah regardless scientific does take
down videl and now joma is all up to the
alien boy
oh
and he's been relying on that reflect
when he's seen the piccolo assist and
scientific takes advantage of it it's a
great choice to do as well because that
would have beaten the um the parry
attempt as well because that you know it
doesn't work anymore so yes
okay my man's hairy dragon rushes that's
kind of why i know it's actually silly
like
obviously unintended but yeah
oh all the infinite oh
all right all right he's out of it for
now man said that you're infinite okay
let's go get some and now
scientific going to work and he's dead
actually that's it
yeah he's dead 100 yeah scientific as
long as he doesn't drop this here one
one one and he's going to be moving on
to losers finals big ups to yoma though
man i'm a big fan of the team right we
saw the gear in the video the super baby
bringing it to the table definitely
always a fan of the variety when it
comes to the composition that we see in
dragon ball fighters so big ups to him
he's getting a fat chunk of points on
that fourth place as well but scientific
gets into the triple digit club at least
100 points to his name as he gets into
losers finals absolutely guys another
quick look at this point the points
break down here um the
online master challenge of course that's
what we're on today
so yoma dropping down their fourth place
gets 70 points to his name i mean it's
it's still still a good start right
yeah 100 right 70 points there's nothing
to sneeze at you're going to be uh
looking good and of course there's going
to be a bunch of tanky ichi online
challenge events as well that he's going
to be able to take uh part in here on
the west coast so he's got a solid start
and he's only going to be building from
there hold up very short trip
wait wait wait did i get it wrong top
four is three out of five
oh is that the case
oh okay yeah all right all right i
didn't realize wait i'm just checking
this one stuff i guess it is otherwise
they wouldn't be playing okay
okay
okay it's three out of five top four
three out of five guys confirmed
so the semifinals so my man yomas okay
live here yeah all right
okay nice
i got confused i i already ran a
tournament today and we did two out of
three losers finals i lose the
semi-finals so yeah i'm just well
yeah my man siren has been i run in all
types of tournaments well you say like
three tournaments in 48 hours yeah man
we did the strive tournament yesterday
we today we did the locals and then now
we've got this but i'm all about the
games man so let's go all right dp wake
up
into the light grenade all right
yeah hold on damage he already spin his
sparking here right so that blue light
you got to get out to actually regen
that there's no freeway out where's the
from yoba though oh i like that sequence
very delayed and then he chases him down
anyway finds the air hit he needs he can
get into the sequence yeah very nice
converting here he's gonna go for the
cross sub level three this is usually
where the babies go
oh no yeah i'm just gonna go for the
level one here follow up let's see
and we'll throw
i like that i'll agree with that um yeah
it's very important
okay let's see young man let's see what
goes for here are the spark from
scientific i mean i like that honestly
absorbing the gogeta assist and then
stuffing them out on the other side
challenging the 6m my man yoma has shown
no fear on the jira and i don't know
what it is about jiren specifically but
he feels so confident and pressing those
buttons yeah
oh wait wake up waking up with it oh
all right
medium to okay never mind drops the
combo oh my goodness yo the 2h
ish
[Music]
okay knocked down
oh that was a bad guard cancel you are
gonna get put into a world of hurt right
now
that was huge honestly that was like a
bait that could really turn around the
entire match however it does not yoman
instead continues to wake up with
buttons he's like bruh
if you don't got meaties then i'm gonna
order the vegetarian dish time and time
again
that's exactly what we just saw my man
was waking up swinging buttons
man
scientific with the mistimed input and
man
that was a real dragon ball right there
both of the players multiple characters
flying through the air exactly
all right here we go
cool
good damage we're doing next
reflex we're
there to air
and honestly next combo with this shell
you could definitely die oh especially
with a 2h starter as a for sure yeah
that was a really really good timing on
that one just reacting perfectly to that
and level 2 will take videl out the
picture
could potentially be one of the
characters can also die on one touch now
exactly could potentially be the last
time that we see that they'll
this set although the two l the ways out
drop the combo what happened
oh that was a dead tien and instead it's
gonna be a dead jiren oh heartbreaker
for yoma yeah that's gonna do it right
there
man scientific closing it out we're on
on
jiren but now baby coming in with three
bars you know he does have the uh
kojita steel as well if he needs to use
it all though that gets there
scientific
neil bring to the ground here you're to
hold on to all the bars it's actually
time to child suit correctly
spun on him no he's trying to call the
the assistant oh what happened although
doesn't matter piccolo gonna go down
here yom are still alive in these guys
wow
all right yeah
takes away some blue life on that as
well
all right here we go
oh he called the see a sister
yeah yeah whatever whatever it is that's
it
you're overhead directly into the rock
scientific that's one of the things you
got to look out for with tn right it's
always so poland we talked about like
broly command grabbing to level three
it's yet overheaded to level three it's
another one of those that just release
your health bar in an instant and great
tool for scientific to go to to close
out the set yeah real solid stuff right
there man you gotta love it um advances
on now to the losers finals he's gonna
get to play against uh of course
i'll play uh the what was the name
alkavich i like a [ __ ] of course yes
yes um yeah so that's the loser's final
right there guys it's gonna be really
really interesting to see who is gonna
advance on to play against zane in the
grand
finals yeah very close set in the
winner's finals we didn't get to see the
end of it but alkavich definitely made
zayn earn the victory so we're going to
see you you know he got a chance to rest
a little bit watch the semi-finals kind
of collect himself yes but yeah no
slouch scientific that's going to be a
tough hill to climb to get back into the
grand final
exactly especially with scientific on a
little bit of a roll now right two over
apology man 3-1 over yo ma he's got some
momentum in this corner
absolutely
so it will be that match coming up for
you guys in just a moment we are ready
for that one um
but yeah man we are we are again three
out of five like you know
it's not usually the standard to have it
i mean that's why i was surprised we got
the the semi-finals three out of five as
well i mean more games is is is perfect
um and it's even better for these guys
because getting to that top four
position now
you get to express yourself a bit more
you know get more matches yes
i'm actually a big fan of losers
semi-finals being like whatever the
winners and losers channels is so i am
i'm with it
yeah
i'm a big fan i'm glad that that is one
of the changes made here so that is a
three out of five territory as soon as
you get into top four going forward keep
that in mind for the dragon ball
fighters the players the viewers
everybody but yeah we have arrived at
losers finals here everybody that you're
gonna see going forward here has gotten
at least 100 points again this is a
master event here for the tenkaichi
online challenge so 200 points for first
place 150 per second and 100 for third
so all these players are going home with
a great start to the season
exactly guys so let's get into it oh we
slightly cut once again or not let me
just make sure that these gentlemen are
not playing oh no so that was a crap
that was a crash because one of them is
not in the lobby anymore
okay so at least we're not going to be
missing any action here while we
re-gather our players
yeah so we're just gonna be waiting for
um
for
uh our player to come back there
these are these are such like scary
teams that we're gonna see algorithm
scientific like both just tremendous
damage output in the wildly scary mm-hmm
yeah it was it was something on
scientific side okay so a slight problem
with his uh with his pc
but um yeah we're gonna be getting him
back on very soon but yeah like it's
like you said these teams are just dude
i'm not trying to play them man no way
for real
these these games we're like sitting
here watching like they can't be dead
we've been we've been playing and
watching this game since its launch and
we're like nah probably they can't be
dead
tn bro it's just massive damage output
the fact that when piccolo starts the
combos on point and he can just loop the
hell zones for more damage it's they're
nasty nasty stuff absolutely but once
again guys thank you so much for joining
us uh this is of course a masters event
for the tenkaichi online challenge so
let me just show you guys the point
breakdown once again while we've got
some down time here
there we go
of course so we're in top three
territory now guys so it is um a hundred
points and up which is a great start to
the season for these guys
yes indeed in all of our top eight today
you see got at least 25 points so even
our
our first round of exits got a cool
little start or two of the season and
then as we're going forward here you can
see the master events are put on by
bandai namco but the community events
are part of what you already see in the
dragon ball fighters environment your
wnfs your nlbcs and the like all of
these are going to be part of the
community events going forward and
depending on the entries is the
depending on the entrance you're going
to earn a different amount of points
that's why you see the 64 plus the 48
plus the 32 plus the 16 plus that is
representing the instrument numbers for
the events so more people equals more
points exactly yeah so really do spread
the word you know guys like
build up your locals get everybody
involved as much as possible and let's
just try and make these uh tournaments
as you know as big and as awesome as
possible you know
of course the tos can reach out via the
dragon ball fights esports portal 2 um
yeah of course to get involved and have
your tournaments represented so you know
keep an eye on the bandai namco twitter
page for that guys
yeah most definitely as we are getting
our players back at it yeah alkovich and
a scientific both back in the room so
we're going to start this off a
momentarily to see who actually gets
that shot at zayn we'll see if alcovich
gets the run back or if a man scientific
can scratch or clog his way back up into
that grand finals i forgot who
scientific lost to in winner's side
because i know he started there i think
yeah he did
yeah let me i mean i'll check the
bracket for you in a moment find out
more yeah
let's get into it now let's go
i have to imagine it was one of these
two it was either alkavich or
right now scientific off to early start
excuse me alkavich off to an early start
here he is on the first player side
we'll get the name switch in a second
yeah we will do it
closer okay here we go right now it is
scientific going to work right now
on uh i guess i guess i guess he wants
us to call him kovich so yeah but i
guess we can do that
i guess we can do that
i've seen the name change in the game
yeah i got you before virginia's
okay very nice and of course the cheat
code damage team this is going to be
more than enough to get the kill here
yeah like it's just so it's so hard
though
goodbye fam we're starting to get used
to it we're starting to get desensitized
to the amount of violence scientific is
bringing mad violence bro
okay oh no reflexes of getting punished
wow this is actually uh
naughty
that's a medium starter that's going to
be a lot of damage
oh no
look at this solo
yeah come on bro
and then you still have to do the meteor
afterwards my scientific gonna put a
stop to that oh no huge choice right
there for malcolm x the fact that he's
gonna be able to like weather the storm
and not only that but take advantage
during the spark while being a character
down this is how you win this set um
not sure if you can
get the kill on this one yeah that would
have been a bit nah there's no way oh
man said
i see you
snatching him
bro
it was a region for the stars he found
it in the megi and
that was wild
that was the code veronica banda snatch
right there
okay here we go
all right oh and again
all right off of the super dash bounce
back yeah all right there we go dr knock
down time
sets up the orb again how makes him
reflect
forcing the option out bro man triple
overhead today
my best was just climbing down there
right there get out of there what are
you doing up there
okay
yeah scientific gonna be able to get the
kill here like more than enough
okay yeah absolutely all the bar he
could possibly want to his name right
here and that's actually going to lock
kovich out of the zebraly limit break as
well right so his main comeback factor
is on the bench piccolo we've seen
definitely is capable of doing the same
thing yeah sparking is available of
course so he'll be able to get out of a
a tight pressure sequence if he still
chooses with that yeah man i feel like
hillary's probably there is critical
wow he still take that that was so good
awareness is out of this world
oh my goodness man he tried to reflect
and he got a level up unfortunately
there
yeah
okay whoa all right ex just larry at
some out there we go gonna get the easy
conversion there with the oil combo and
look at the damage the scaling was so
minimal
yeah
now level three is gonna try to beat
this spark in an interesting way no just
goes with the dash
okay
no follow-up though
oh just dash in his face hit him with
the hezzy right there you saw the
counter could come out
all right cubbies get the kill here
yeah that's pretty huge yeah probably
going to level three yeah i had to spend
a little bit more bar than i think he
wanted to but you know it's still it's
still fine still in the game like tien
and gogeta don't have that much life
left so
yeah i think that was well worth
considering they're both in one hit
territory but no
late clip trying to move a little bit
too early right there and yeah my mans
is gonna get that health deleted through
the regen
yeah easily man the character like tien
he just cuts through that like butter
man like this guy just hits so insanely
hard and yeah he's still alive in this
um
this guy's been going in
you'd love to see it scientific you know
he wants to make it to that grand finals
yeah a man scientific letting it be
known that just because he took a quick
trip to the losers doesn't mean he's not
going to be in that grand finals
position here already like we said has a
lot of momentum defeated apology man 2-0
defeated yoma 3-1 this man is on a roll
here and kobe's gotta put a stop to the
momentum any way you can yeah absolutely
and i mean
it wasn't like that was a very i feel
like it was a very close game like that
was not a one-sided match by any means
so you know kovich can definitely do
this just has to keep that composure
together
right now
see if he can kind of make the most out
of the star
guys scientific gets his woke up buttons
oh no but you can't be dropping like
that that's unfortunate
yeah exactly right he's trying to get
the big damage with the blue goku
combo's not easy ended up dropping it
because of it we'll see if he takes that
blue damage away or that blue life away
instead just takes the slide knock down
okay cross up there oh he actually goes
low that time afterwards that was tricky
kovic's in trouble now this blue goku
i'm gonna take a a little bit a little
bit of damage but there we go ly grenade
level three
knocked down
wow spends the extra bar as well for the
okie
goes low oh man
yeah i mean another thing about piccolo
is that his combo will be lasting kind
of long with the the assist extension
here so you can see he finally gets out
of that meter penalty range was built in
a lot but
not enough to get him back down yeah i
think he could have definitely killed
there oh my goodness oh what he actually
could have converted
yes
the the the uh the piccolo was just hit
but was unable to uh convert that
scientific though gets the kill on blue
yeah that projectile lingers right so
even if you're stuck in the animation
for the throw it's still gonna connect
as soon as that cinematic ends yeah
there's no reason why this you know this
team i feel like
very very good synergy
wow
i have no clue there was some type of
thing activated that kind of paused the
screen for a second but i couldn't tell
what it was
okay there we go
down again sets up for all of me
okay and again the genesis goes low
scientific making it happen now
that was huge honestly that like super
delayed demon elbow to switch sides plus
the tienes has to follow up a very very
smart way to turn it recognize that he
was going to hold the vanish because of
the spark and challenge as well what a
decision that that was a great decision
right there from scientific manner one
of the things that he's super good at is
just his awareness situational awareness
and now here we go there's going to be
enough to get the kill for sure two bar
spend that's gonna do it last character
now for kovich
that was a really good stuff like the
fact that he was felt confident
challenging like there was a gap
presented there that wouldn't normally
be there right if you didn't so it could
have been like a little bit of a fuzzy
match but like that was just very
impressive hmm
absolutely okay oh my goodness you're
the defensive 2h that was so good
ah that's going to be a dead goji all
day
fam planet gonna get smoked
i love it just watched it take him to
the ground
and the slow one as well
admired his work
that's a lot of character to hit without
the dumper bro the butter gun
okay
spark this time
scientific now oh what no he didn't
convert he did but that he didn't
no
oh
oh no it whipped again crouching
that looks so stupid because he's so big
yeah
you know
right through the hair just grabbing
blonde blonde streaks
all right piccolo in now but don't
forget this is a level two spark now oh
my goodness yeah he just dashed up to a
manga stand lighted as a the esports
normals of a super bowl yeah man
okay
oh there it is the chest bump and that's
gonna seal the deal for sure the second
game will go to kovich
the gang's delicious rears its head at
the end my man just use the stand medium
the chest pump i cannot believe what
what a decision to go with right there
though i mean very very small bringing
it back that's a that's a one upset now
right
yes yes yes yeah yeah tied up tied up
one one now one one uh we're gonna go
into the third game momentarily um but
man like this has been
it's been an interesting one for sure
back and forth i mean i have to say the
way this sign sign like have you got to
give coverage credit
scientific it was looking like it was
all him that second game but of course
you know you can't count out the
legendary super saiyan
legendary for a reason
right he's even got the tag you see it
right there at the bottom legendary
super saiyan on the profile he knows
where his bread is buttered
he knows it bro you'd love to see it
that's plan a right that's what it's
called that's plan a the rest of the
team is plan b
that was forbidden starters man got him
with the second hit the auto combo
though oh my goodness don't reflect
anything scientific back in the driver's
seat
in a big way
yeah and that was like a classic dragon
ball star right it's like all forbidden
starter hits you and then you whiff
reflect and die like that's just how the
game goes sometimes
dragon ball two touches it's out here
bro
very very important
okay
oh with the assist as well
i mean yeah he can reflect all of that
the challenge there from scientific he
did not believe in this out says i see
straight through it
like i gotta pick a little two fam i've
done my homework here look at that
speaking of homework yeah you can't
reflect that yeah that koji is so good
at setting up
oh both of them can't keep both of them
but still
ovish will be happy with that building a
lot of bar here with the piccolo taking
to the ground conserve that meter for
now yeah
vanishes goes back oh and the two a
scientific everything going his way this
game
wasting down the spark time as well look
at this
yeah ready yeah so you can reflect in an
improv tag that's a great answer to a
lot of those setups but man he was ready
for that like he plays piccolo as well
fam
yeah he legit just stood there and
waited it was like all right football
coming this way right through the goal
post and then again you can see just
waiting for whatever he was gonna do to
switch out the character counters it
perfectly once again
over again um there
okay super dash just doing stuff
but now here comes the legendary one
oh boy plan a commence
why scientific against the big crouch
medium though
yeah this is a big combo man
wait is he dead
don't tell me he's dead
yeah with the tien he's
close close oh my goodness again why do
i even think to second guess why do i
even think to questions yet
yeah i don't know like that is an absurd
amount of damage
like
crazy this guy's going in like
scientific
but like he's not happy that he lost
that second game you could see it
that was a statement game range like you
could see it in his gameplay
man sent a message he wanted that
message not only to get to kovish but
also beyond right he was like zayn i
hope you're watching this one because
this is what your future might be
looking like
absolute facts all right so we're going
into the the uh the next game the fourth
game of the set guys of a potential five
but let's see if scientific wants it to
go down to that because the way he's
playing i don't think we're gonna see
that
yeah i don't think so either oh but okay
excuse me kovic just straight up no l a
man's is a sober yeah
oh
okay
oh my goodness the dragon rush those
dragon brushes where they're a bit
further back they're actually like i
feel like they're hard at the tech man
okay yeah exactly i just think they're
like you think of it happening less
right like usually you see something
like that at the point with my rush
connecting there so when they sneak in
from farther away it's even harder to uh
kind of take into account exactly and
kervich they're using that spark to get
through forget the 2h oh the piccolo oh
no betrayal
the namekian
oh man look at this
and i really like mark from scientific
he's like all right the scramble gave me
a second chance at life let me make the
most of it and then dragon rush is the
reflect attempt huge start for this game
for exactly living rent-free in his head
right now that could be the last time we
see blue for the set potentially if
scientific has anything to say about it
just putting the big boots out right
back at you
just pick a button with piccolo in the
air it's probably good yeah for real
bro nice beauty oh my goodness fire's
back with it as well
yeah it's very you know we talked about
being aware of how your play style
affects the other player that goes
doubly so for mirror matches like
whenever you use an option you got to
consider your opponent thinking about
the same thing
scientific jets they're hit there with
the cross-up demon elbow
okay knock down time sets up the media
and again it's these reflects that have
been getting coverage into so much
trouble reach
and it's one of the things with dragon
ball players right is that like we want
to reflect we want to do something that
doesn't involve blocking because like
once you start blocking it could really
be hard to stop exactly you've just been
betting on the reflex and trying to play
that type of game and it hasn't been
working out
okay there we go
all right very nice
firing back this could be what he needs
definitely
i mean it's got to be at least a morale
boost right you're starting off the big
bully see if you can get one yeah banish
your vanish i want to keep this corner
2h on the raw tag this is how we get
brought back into the set no
big drop opportunity that could be
terrible right there
okay
oh although although
now not challenging
here oh my goodness piccolo coming in
clutch as always and again into the
level three they're gonna let gogeta
recover
okay
whoa
i'm not sure what he tried there
yeah again click whatever it was gotta
be careful calling that assist but not
that one perfectly called for the tn and
i mean yeah we've seen this story once
twice thrice my man scientific is going
to the grand finals via the level three
from the gold cheetah well done the big
bang kamehameha does it for him there
and of course that is going to be that
as you said wrench
grand finals is now set it is going to
be zane versus scientific
right that piccolo assist call at the
end right there that blew up the vanish
timing that was like that that actually
was where the set was
because
or kovish was really starting to bring
it back right a lot of momentum was
coming in his favor he was finding smart
vanish timings and that's what we love
to see in fighting games though the fact
that those vanishes were successful
that's what scientific used against him
later right he was like okay you've been
kind of doing this a bit i'm catching on
to the rhythm of when you like to do it
so then he made sure his point character
recovered in time and the piccolo says
blew him up that was expert adjustment
absolutely yeah really really nice stuff
guys so there we go the grand finals is
now set you can see it right here
scientific has fought his way through
that loser's bracket to get the game
with zayn there so it's going to be a
run back from the winner semis let's see
how this one goes
so yeah yeah scientific did fall to zayn
then so that's the only player he's
going to lose to today if he does fall
here in grand finals but maybe the
redemption arc can be completed of
course zane is in at the winner's aside
so he's got to face or he's a scientific
it's got to be him three games before he
gets a chance at that first place um it
could be so annoying like getting double
japanese as well so let's see if
scientific can come with a different
strategy i mean he does have two
potential sets
with zayn uh to come up here so to
defeat the guy
two times
in three out of five sets you know a guy
that beat you 2-0 and put you in the
losers bracket that's rough that's not
an easy task to do range
no yeah not anywhere close to easy right
because there's already a set of intel
that your opponent has so yeah it's all
about taking into account the
adjustments not only from the loser side
that you have to do to get back to w's
that you didn't get in the first place
but the fact that you gave them intel to
work with so now you got to take into
consideration what you did in those
first games how they might respond going
forward considering they might want to
stay a step to her head right and not
just kind of rest on their laurels but
yeah it is going to be a good one 100
and big ups i want to say once again the
covish 100 points that is nothing to
sneeze at right there that is a great
start to your dragon ball season exactly
you know 100 points up on the board you
know that's
super super good to have uh going into
this season of the world championship
you know like this is a new season it's
a fresh start for everybody
um
so yeah come and show your skills guys
and of course i'm sure the players that
you see entering the master events will
also be entering a lot of the uh locals
a lot of the community events that you
see out there so be sure to tune in to
those you know support them here on
twitch and
yeah man like you know just
we want to see the community grow and
you know really
go in this year so yeah man like with
with this new patch as well i feel like
it's a great time to uh to get some uh
get some dragon ball going
yeah a hundred percent man i mean i i
really do think dragon ball fighters did
on the front of like bandai namco and
like the tournament scene and all that i
mean they pretty much done their side of
the deal right like there was a crazy
patch that introduced a bunch of new
things all kinds of different team
compositions are viable there's a bunch
of online community events that are part
of going towards the world tour finals
we're going to get three back-to-back
offline events in december i mean as a
dragon ball fan i'm pretty happy right
now yeah nah for sure for sure i'm
really enjoying it you know and like
like we had man
like we said we were lucky to have the
um
the uh the france fest uf the usa event
that was really really nice that was a
taste
of the offline environment uh that we
are gonna get coming up in december guys
of course you know we've got this to
look forward to it's going to be super
super exciting
yeah man you can see it's all starting
off with europe the 4th the 5th of
december in the usa 11th and 12th and
then the 18th and 19th of december for
japan incredible stuff and i mean yeah
we've seen the usa versus france event
lit a fire under everybody right
obviously europe is like hey we're the
best but obviously usa wants to get
better wants to get our revenge and
we've seen goichi already tweet about
like europe you need to chill out son
like i know you guys think you're the
best but wait we haven't gone to play
yet so i mean i i can't wait till all
this comes to a head at early 22 or 2022
as well yeah it's gonna be super super
exciting man of course the but this is
the next stage that's the the what we're
going to be looking forward to guys
right now we're still in the
online tenkaichi challenge phase so
you know
this is what they're fighting towards
you know if you want to represent your
region you need to get the points in
this online uh stage of the tournament
of the of the
of the season and then move on to the
regionals so yeah it's gonna be super
super good from here on out man like
this is this is the start of uh an
exciting season for dragon ball fighters
and they've been exciting games today as
well because that everybody that has
come through gotten points the viewers
at home everybody watching i mean yeah i
can't wait to get into this grand finals
because i think zayn and scientific
they're both very much playing like this
season of dragon ball right you can see
both of them trying to implement the new
strategies trying to uh really abuse the
damage output from some of these
characters as well they're very smart i
ain't going to lose the character select
screen that's for damn sure um exactly
bro now we do have scientific in the
lobby here we are going to get it going
guys we are ready
for the grand finals guys
let's go
and the finals indeed for the first
dragon ball tenkaichi master online
event baby kicking it off here at the us
west of course it's gonna be u.s east
events events throughout europe japan
all kinds of stuff to come we are just
getting started but again this is the
very first grand finals zane winner side
advantage here scientific coming from
losers the man that put him into losers
in the first place is zayn so we'll see
if the redemption can be completed let's
go guys of course
zayn in that winner's side
gets that advantage you know okay there
we go nice take on the dragon rush there
oh okay
challenge such a great job utilizing the
zamasu oh my goodness
i can't believe he ended up stopping his
sequels right there baiting out the dp
punishing cleanly you're gonna get a
dragon ball but you're gonna pay with a
lot of your life
okay oh the spark up there all right
[Music]
yeah that was super dash that hit so
high up there the vertical one gonna get
the advantage uh and use that 2h
okay very smart from scientific and yeah
i really like the fact that he
prioritized holding on to his entire
team here super saiyan 4 gogeta is
a key piece to this team oh yeah for
sure
again just go over the pressure all the
dp whiffing and getting punished right
there
medium star ton of damage on the board
dead character
yeah
whatsoever that time send them down one
more in the beerus
that's a good look
bro zayn is looking ridiculous today
this guy can can anyone stop him i don't
think so
it's not looking like it today man
so you're looking like he's playing out
of this world
okay there we go that 2m really paying
off
he he's really good at like locking down
his opponent with an assist and i think
his opponents are just thinking they can
hold that back
not respecting the range and speed on
beerus's crotch media
okay and the extension of course this is
gonna be just enough yes he gets the
extra bar might not even need it just a
two bar spend should do it range oh it
does indeed zayn looks ridiculous today
wow yeah man once again deleting the
character has a bar to his name android
21 in i mean all three of his characters
are just like a real pain to play
against in the neutral and then when
you're just a solo character it's gonna
be even more of a nightmare finds the
falling jump m yeah i mean this is
gonna be a tall order for scientifically
to come back
okay there we go
the wake up button challenge right there
i like it
okay and again that zamasu for the
pressure oh man scientific was swinging
right there you saw the light
okay yeah exactly
he's trying to steal his turn back but
right now he can't
do downtech instant airdash bypasses the
stand medium all right
yeah
getting that hit there level three here
okay tien does not lose as much life on
that as he used to but the command grab
he's gonna have to spend a lot of bar on
this one but he should be able to close
out range
yeah he should here at least oh yeah i
think we need one bar here yeah
nice
clean stuff scientific
zamasu can definitely get smoked in
another combo beer is still with full
life it's gonna take a little bit more
work to get him but
right now he's got to get past that
zamasu first
they make that 5m so good for zamasu now
it's so fast okay
so the flight's coming out from
scientifically respecting it all but
again he's been so good at flying around
utilizing that beerus assist yeah being
in the vicinity to convert from it to i
mean yeah zane again looking ridiculous
and i feel like that's one of the big
changes to the game this season right
they made a lot more of the um assists a
lot more usable in neutral so now you
know it rewards you for visually
confirming the hits and you know getting
the pickup you know you can move around
they give you get a lot more hits done
on these on these assists now as well so
yeah it's just really really really good
and we saw again that's one of the
strategies strategies that like to go
back to another point earlier on that a
lot of the french players were using
they were using a lot of these um
assists and just picking up in the
neutrals so
and i feel like zayn has employed that
strategy perfectly into his game plan
really making it work good stuff
yeah and in conjunction like the hit
stun increase in conjunction with the
speed flight increase on zamasu it
really played at these some of the
conversions right you're like this would
have nowhere been near possible before i
know
it's actually kind of crazy how
different it is like i'm sure like if we
go back and look at the season one to
three zamasu now it would be like what
on earth like
yeah it's a different guy
different character
oh man
right now there was so much work with
this character he's dead
oh yeah
gonna need that oh magic we'll have to
spend two bars unfortunately but still
man what
what is round stuff his aim
not even a scratch of damage on him the
start
okay and again
one of the things you can use uh
beerus's
uh options for his his jump 2h
um
his you know his special moves they can
also be used as movement tools you know
so really really
oh right okay
yeah i think zayn's done a pretty good
job of utilizing those things in
conjunction with these assists right
both of the assists he has go across the
screen once beerus is on the uh on point
so he's been doing a good job kind of
sneaking and crossing someone not
scientific though trying to stem the
bleeding got the spark up i'm gonna be
able to convert the combo from there and
that's why zayn i love that the scramble
situation preserves going back to the
neutral he's been so good in this
instance why not use the spark to return
to that
yo you said scientific went for a
preemptive reflect right there but zane
just switching up the timing on that all
throw
okay that was so good and then you
followed it up with the android 21. oh
just waiting very disciplined combo
conversion right there on the assist
okay i'm back at this again man this has
been all insane right now we are seeing
a repeat of what happened to winner
semifinal zane with a solid performance
so far over scientific i mean tien is
still there in the back but man no spark
a full team it's going to be tough
mm-hmm you know zamasu right back on
point of full health zamasu both this is
you just got to deal with and see the
reflex but the fact that he has these
teleports these flight is just so mobile
great chase down though really making
the most out of the chow block store
that's right okay tries to just time the
pressure okay the iad working out though
scientific should be able to get the
kill here he will have to spend the
level three of course to get it
definitely worth it to kill zamasu
yeah please kill zamasu bro
yeah yeah well worth yeah level four
spend there
of course but here she comes full health
android 21.
oh my goodness your beerus assistant
neutral looks kind of stressful i can't
lie
yeah yeah definitely especially when you
like have to chase down your opponent
you're getting into these weird
situations where they might be crossing
you up at the moment it comes out
great conversion right there the up
fireball
pushing him towards the corner
bro
the jump cross up android 21.
yo the baggy pants have a hitbox bro
that was crazy
for sure man
you know usually the parachute saves
lives but the parachute pants they
destroy them apparently 2-0 for zayn
like that perfectly timed on that
crosstalk that was a ridiculous setup
right there the fact that he
was reading the neutral like that and
crosstalk the moment he landed got the
counter hit on top of it you weren't
going to be able to do anything that was
to tell you what zane is just in his
comfort zone right now you can see it
scientific is unable to get anything
going it's always down to anchor tien
it's just
and he just can't make things he can't
make
what he wants to do come to fruition
it's all zane bro
it's been in complete control from start
to finish for him we've talked about how
good his team is at that i think yeah if
you're not used to playing against this
guy or a show like this like it's gonna
take a lot of matches before you really
get a handle on what to do and we're
seeing that play out right here he is
4-0 against scientific in this
tournament yeah he's the one that put
him into losers so that's it it is not
an easy thing to overcome that's it and
he's on set point now he just needs to
win one more and the tournament is his
so let's see if i mean scientific man
it's now or never bro
what wow did he get behind him like that
he tried the side switch combo but
unable unable to get it oh a blue combo
though all right
yeah one of those words like zayn wasn't
ready to air attack just yet
the falling h i feel i feel like
kojita's uh jump he's one of the best
heavy buttons in the game man like it
just has a
ridiculous hitbox it hits like high up
it hits low down it's just it's just
insane
yeah i wonder if zayn in a similar
situation he's gonna lose his zamasu
here but in a similar situation that we
saw earlier when he played that he did a
cross under jab and i wonder if he like
did a jab and the dashes didn't come out
so he got he got counter hit right there
yeah sure yeah it could be
okay tried to go for that two emma
beerus again and i feel like he's been
so unpredictable with that approach as
well like you just can't lock this
beerus down like he's just coming at you
from all angles
oh yeah and you can see my goodness name
just ready for when it even whips
immediately micro dashing putting the
grounding normals on them
very aware constantly oh my goodness
trying to skate on in gets the costume
no conversion though
harry
yeah
oh he tried the the panic dp right there
airborne you know he just tried it but
scientific one step ahead here we go
could this be what he needs
knock down time
i do feel like that's oh the game is
gonna be bringing up vp again his vps
have been pretty on point throughout the
tournament so
oh god
he has got all the bar in the world
right now bro and i think you can get
the kid actually level two into level
three should do it right yep
wow
yeah blow it up and then there we go
level three we'll get the kill for zayn
on that piccolo
that's huge man putting piccolo on the
bench like this getting the full stocks
on android 21 as well scientific does
have his sparking available but still
this is a big w for zayn with the way
the set started oh the match started
yeah no that's a great turnaround
honestly that's he couldn't have asked
for more than that situation actually
okay great night from scientific
oh what happened there delayed the bun
too much
oh what a pickup though this is what we
were talking about the pickups in
neutral look at that from zane
like wow
nice job too
managing both the uh slots while still
getting the combo oh he has to spark
here
like i don't know man like i feel like
oh no he didn't and he's gonna lose tien
wait wait wait wait is he going to lose
you
know the penalty of course wait a second
no
okay still alive
i do think that's why he didn't spark in
the first place because he thought the
mirror penalty wouldn't allow her to
kill and he was right but i think this
is going to be picking up still the
regen health here and not building any
bar
oh i'm going to get it at the very end
here but yeah i wouldn't kill so i'm
just going to hold on to the meter for
now yeah good good choice from zane but
now the guard cancel is blocked and
guess what medium starter
yeah
damage again
the extension and the building back to
three bars now you gotta guess for this
character if you guess wrong here you're
gonna have to guess for your last
character okay let's see i mean the dp
is an option right now but no just
blocks it successfully oh man look at
this
the pickup though scientific still alive
yeah but now you know we were talking
about zayn having a lot of money in the
bank this time scientific with the
warmest fair
three bars here for the hard knockdown
city what's next okay oh just the empty
dash dragon rush that is gonna be enough
to kill off the android 21. yeah that is
just keep it simple go straight into
level one all right here we go
scientifically live here beerus he's
gotten a good
read on a couple of dps here in this
game too so
beerus got to be
careful all the cross up not enough
though okay the orbs are still there
though look at this just just non-stop
yes not your turn and the god of
destruction is here to destroy lives
whenever you're turned by look at things
all right there we go scientific though
trying to stay alive with that tien and
it's always been this anchor tien this
oh that was a perfectly timed super dash
okay
so he's gonna be oh
no no no
scientific i think got caught trying to
calculate
has been the least valuable player the
entire tournament the entire time
we saw that earlier with uh apology man
the same thing happened but bro your
champion for the opening event
for the the dragon ball fighters world
championship tenkai online
i take hee online master challenge is
none other than zayn big performance
from him man like that was an impressive
run through that tournament man like
just dominating games for sure
big props to zane 200 points to his name
to start the dragon ball event that is a
great way to start qualifying yourself
for your regional event of course for
him it's going to be the usa but man i
think from start to finish he looked
like the most complete player today he
is a team with very good the composition
of it i think it's just so strong to
have these characters that are so mobile
and present so many ways of getting
around the screen and presenting
obstacles while doing it for the other
player and that was just a textbook
dragon ball fighter style that he played
great stuff to zane yeah really
impressive look at that run man just
boom boom boom i mean kovich nearly made
it happen in the winner's final but it
wasn't enough uh zayn just looking solid
and
yeah that is it like you said wrench a
great start to the to the season for him
and
you know hopefully we can see some more
of that exciting beerus play zamasu play
um down the line that was really i'd
love to see more of him play honestly
yeah for sure i mean yeah and starting
with 200 points hopefully enter some of
the community events as well to ensure
that spot in the usa regional finals
yeah i want to see this player up
against uh the usa's finest right
hopefully we we get to see that that's
always a beautiful thing getting to see
some of these players that are kind of
constricted to their region they get to
uh you know sold their wild oats with
the international competition and
national competition in this case as
well in the play players that he doesn't
normally get to play so yeah big ups to
zane man looked impressive as hell
absolutely but with that guys that is
gonna be it from us here on the uh
opening event for the world championship
this season uh ringed it was a lot of
fun chopping up with you as always
brother man thank you so much for
holding it down with me um yeah but guys
be sure to get involved on social media
you know be sure to spread the word and
let's just get it man because from now
on we got just seasons and seasons of
games and uh lots of exciting stuff to
come so be sure to stay tuned guys
that's us done for the day and we will
see you very very soon everybody take
care see you later
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you